Hello, hello, hello.
Hello.
Everybody.
How are you?
Wait, hold on.
My mic is all messed up.
How did this happen?
Okay, I'll just...
I...
I'm just not gonna worry about it.
We'll be busy for this one, but remember, the most important rule in the zombie apocalypse is to have fun!
Thank you, Organizer!
I hope whatever you're busy with You get done Easily Hello, poinsettia Hello Busy with you and the...
Take a break Tea Unless The paper is due tonight I don't know I'm a better Under pressure Kind of Kind of gal You know if I'm like Oh gosh I have a paper I'll do it like day before.
Glad to see you're all right.
That hawk swooping down at the end of last stream sounded like it was out for blood.
For those that don't know what they're talking about, you can go watch my unboxing stream of Metal Gear acrylics.
And I got attacked by a hawk.
Whose name was Mike.
Hyped for some more tell-tale shenanigans.
Whoa, thank you so many people coming back.
Tomorrow's my B-Day, can I get a happy birthday?
Spoon, happy birthday!
And your birthday is on the big Nintendo Direct.
Everybody's talking about it.
Everybody.
Everybody's hyped about it.
My Mike do a watch along.
I feel like I should.
Everyone's like, it's the big thing.
People are saying that it might be Smash.
People are saying it might be New Mario Movie.
Baby boy, thank you so much for the fun.
Good day.
Hi, hi, Minta.
Hello.
No, walking dead casualties starting now.
Yeah.
Everybody will live.
Today was pretty hard, but having my OG stream makes it better.
Thank you.
Chibudo, I hope you can relax.
Silk Song.
We've got Tomodachi Live.
We've got Silk Song.
I hope we get more Tomodachi Live news, though.
They only announced it.
They didn't really say, like, a date or anything before, right?
I hope we get more of that.
Half-Life 3 is definitely going to be announced tomorrow.
For sure, that's the last thing that I could ever manifest.
Is a Half-Life 3.
That's...
Tomorrow?
Tomorrow!
Tomorrow, Half-Life 3.
You heard it here first, folks.
Some of that life is Q1, 2026?
Really?!
Production hotline on the 25th!
Yes!
I did, but unfortunately I don't think I'll be able to...
Oh wait, 25th.
Hold on, let me check the calendar.
Oh, 25th?
Oh, maybe!
25th?
Oh wait, that's Japan 25th.
Yes, because TGS Wednesday, Thursday is a business day.
No, Thursday, Friday, Business Day, Saturday.
Wait, am I getting it wrong?
Saturday, Sunday, open to the public?
Am I getting it wrong?
I don't remember.
But yeah.
Kodishi, Senpai, welcome back.
Thank you so much.
So I can't say, just so I wanted to say hi.
Oh, good.
Thanks for saying hi.
New Animal Crossing?
I wish.
Is the...
Wait, the mobile game is still going.
Or they, uh, uh, they, uh, what was it?
Um, they, like, opened it for everybody or something.
They, like, made it so everybody can get all the stuff, I think.
It's offline app now?
Okay, okay.
Last update is this month!
They ended it, but made it all offline.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, that's what I thought.
17 months of Minto You're so close to getting The rainbow wisp That would be 24 months Wait Oh wait, that's not close at all Never mind, hold on Wait, three Is two Seven Seven Seven Seven
It's...
That's...
Oh, less than a decade.
Less than a decade!
Wait, no, hold on.
Wait, a decade would be years.
Wait, hold on.
I'm wrong again.
Wait.
Wait,
wait, it's months.
Wait, it's seven months, right?
Wait, hold on.
Yeah, you're at 17 months.
And in seven months, God.
More than seven years.
okay I'm okay I was like wait seven years is a really long time actually am I even still gonna be around in seven years I'm
okay I'm okay I hope so I might still be around but would you guys even still be around
Ducky, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Here's two dollars.
I know maps are.
That's not two dollars.
Thank you.
Agent Heroic.
Oh.
the flow of time is weird in the VTuber world I'm a ghost I don't know anything about the concept of time I admit I don't need it get well suited yeah forever 19 by the way exactly exactly exactly it's two dollars after YouTube is that what we're okay we're at we're taking after the YouTube cut okay got it Minto is eternal we will watch heaven or the place the place but anyway welcome back to the walking dead we are on chapter four um I I was like what did we end on last time I remember we made it to Savannah
And, uh...
Do you see Time Magic?
Wait, this, this...
Oh no, your name is...
Wait, there we go.
This Cortez Captor Sakura!
Happy birthday!
Wait, this...
Like a card Captor Sakura.
This Cortez Captor Sakura happy happy birthday happy birthday thank you so much um we made it to savannah and then um then or did we make it to savannah yeah but regardless regardless we learned that clem has been talking to somebody on the radio not yet okay we're on the way we're on The big thing was that the guy that Clem is talking to,
which is kind of crazy.
We're on our way.
We're on the road to Savannah.
Yeah, Duck did not make it.
I'm kind of nervous.
Because, you know, I know it's the Walking Dead, but, you know, most media is a little afraid of killing off children.
And I was like, Clem is going to live.
But then Duck died and I was like...
Uh...
So...
Of course no spoilers since it's my first time playing.
And, uh...
Yes.
So let's just play.
Play.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Episode 4, Around Every Corner.
Duck only died because he didn't high-five him.
I don't believe that.
Yeah, objective is to protect Clem.
Previously on the Walking Dead.
Shut up, Carly.
Oh, this was crazy.
This was so insane.
I can't believe this was- Oh my gosh, sorry.
I forgot it was gonna happen.
Oh no, just then.
Oh my gosh, it's so crazy.
I don't know much about you, folks.
But I can tell you, sure as the sun's gonna come up to- Oh, well!
Thank you so much for the thank you, dude!
I guess, and that girl ain't good.
Sarah's happy birthday!
So many birthdays!
Happy, happy birthday!
I'll do it.
Oh, and then we killed Doug.
We need to help find a boat.
It's our best bet at safety.
Okay, but we'll be in Savannah, and my parents were in Savannah.
Okay, we'll look for them.
I was the one giving the bandits supplies.
What?
And then, Ben!
It's only fault.
We gotta jump!
Wow!
What?
No way!
And then this guy almost died.
Shit!
Can't wait for you to get to Savannah, Clementine.
I got your parents right here.
And you'd be sure to find me, whether League wants you to or not.
Now, what I did...
Oh, the fuck.
This is so... This is not...
Episode 3 was so insane.
I... I... I am so...
It was so great.
Crazy!
Chapter 3 was so crazy!
Oh my gosh.
A lot happened despite feeling so short.
Yeah.
The Walking Minky.
Poor Kacha didn't even get a mention.
We just lumped her and ducking together, I suppose.
It's our welcome back!
Thank you.
Thank you guys so much for 7.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Savannah!
Is this Savannah?
Looks Savannah-like.
I've always wanted to go to Savannah because I've always heard that they have good ghost places.
Stop yelling!
We need to be quiet!
Hella haunted?
I'll be able to talk to people.
Oh,
he's keeping the walkie.
Can't I just hold it?
Um, not now, Clementine.
Just for a little while.
I need you to focus.
We're getting real close to where my mom and dad are.
I need you to lock in, Clem.
I need you to focus.
Lock in.
Keep your attention on the street.
Okay, sorry.
Pao's onede.
His leg's pretty bad.
Uh-oh.
I'm fine.
You're not fine.
You need to rest.
He needs to rest.
Kenny, how much further?
Kenny, how much farther to the riverfront?
Yeah.
There should be just a few more blocks up ahead.
And there'll be boats there?
There sure as hell better be.
There'll be boats.
Have to be.
After.
It's going to be okay.
Kenny knows what he's doing.
Okay, Ben.
What the hell?
Oh, that's bad timing.
Oh.
These are automated?
Maybe the city's not so dead after all.
moving no one's ringing that bell it's automatic on a timer what kind of church bell goes off at 20 past the hour oh maybe they see them walking they're like get inside oh someone's up there are you sure I don't see anything I know I know what I saw I'm telling you there's someone up in that bell tower someone alive
of the street now i thought you said that thing didn't work it didn't yeah it didn't um are you in the tower who is this is that you up in the bell tower thank you hi hello welcome in everybody hat dot hat dot what the hell was that is someone trying to with us sounded more like a warning yeah i think all the zombies are gonna come after the noise no tools.
What are you yammering on about?
Thank you guys for the gift, and thank you!
Remack, thank you, rugber, but thank you!
Oh, yeah, see, here they come!
Here they come!
All the zombies!
Did they do that on purpose?
Did they get the zombies in?
Super liminal, thank you so much!
Uh, run?
Oh, I meant to do run!
Run!
Follow me!
I meant to say run, my
Yeah.
Ew.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
I got him.
Easy peasy.
Too close.
Don't you think?
Ben!
No!
Ben, help her.
Ben help her.
Ben?
Why is it not getting that guy?
Wait, I was trying to get that guy.
It wasn't getting that guy.
You move the hell out of here.
I'll catch up with you.
So loud all of a sudden.
Did I keep missing?
My bad.
Ben?
Move your asses!
River Streets right up ahead!
That's not all.
Minto will remember them.
I'll give me a fucking break.
Minto will remember that.
Chuck!
No, Chuck.
Oh my god, Chuck.
Shit, he's in trouble.
We gotta help him.
These things are not that fast.
I don't understand.
Like, I know there's a lot of them.
I know there's a lot, but like...
Oh, oh, Chuck.
Chuck.
Minto remembers everything.
I'll get the door Oh my god Oh need Oh You okay Yeah You've opened up your room You're bleeding Oh gosh Shit It's gonna get infected We've got to get him inside Clean him up Yeah Kenny how's that door coming I'm working on it I'm working on it We'll work faster Would you Won't be long before those things outside Figure out where we I'll find a way!
I'll find it!
Let me see if I can find this a way here.
Yeah, yeah.
Also, Ben, what the hell?
I'm gonna kill you.
Ben.
What the hell?
Um, yeah, about- About what happened back there on the street.
I know.
I don't know what happened.
I just froze up.
No, you didn't.
You ran!
Hasn't that ever happened to you?
Just hear what I'm saying to you.
You put that girl in danger again.
It won't be walkers you have to worry about.
Ooh.
I hear you.
I hate him.
Think we can get in through one of these windows?
Man, I don't think so.
Whoever owned this place had them all barred up.
Wow, they're like crazy.
Looks pretty solid.
Yeah, like crazy boarded up.
Justified hate.
How do you think Kenny's holding out?
I don't think this is the time for our chit chat.
All he can think about is finding a boat.
He definitely doesn't want to talk about Kacha and Duck, at least not with me.
No one wants to talk to you, Ben.
I'm going to go check things out.
It's time to take 67 cents from Ben.
Clem, don't stand so close to the gate.
You're worrying me.
Do you think the dead people saw us come back here?
Are they going to find us?
Uh, try not to worry.
Try not to worry.
Even if they saw us, they can't get in here.
Yeah, true.
We did.
Why can't they?
We're a lot smarter than they are.
They're just like dumb animals.
Stupid animals.
He used to have a pet hamster.
One night he figured out how to open the door to his cage.
And when we woke up, he'd eaten half a box of cookies.
Oh, I thought she was going to say he ate himself.
Hamsters are so strange.
This time we're the cookies.
Just stay away from the gate.
Never let Ben have anything nice.
Yeah, stay away from the gate.
Hamsters, like, will, like, eat them, eat their friends.
Hamsters, well, hamsters are, hamsters are really, uh-oh, hamsters are no good.
How's he looking?
I'm alright.
You're not alright.
You've reopened your wound, you're losing blood, and God only knows what might have gotten in there.
It could be infected.
It could be...
No offense, but you really need to work on your bedside manner.
Um, we'll take care of it.
She's just worried about you, ma'am.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
We're gonna get you fixed up in no time.
Yeah.
as soon as we're inside yeah he's a nice guy thanks man oh you please go and help kenny we need to get him inside now i'm trying just sit tight hey i'm not going anywhere clam are you okay will we be inside soon yeah if i'm yapping with everybody we're not gonna get inside getting cold out here oh she's cold okay dirt mound looks like something was buried here The hamster.
Doghouse.
Aw.
Just a doghouse.
Fountain.
I'm not thirsty enough to drink that yet.
Ew.
I hope not.
Let's see.
Oh, the dog?
The pet door.
What's this?
Looks like there's some kind of pet door here.
Crawl through.
I tried it already.
That's lock two.
What?
ever heard of a locked doggy just just kick it in my neighborhood wouldn't just like that it's it's radio control my pet hamster was a collar with a chip in it so the door only opens when the dog gets close to it no shit every day's a school day just kick it in all right so where's the dog they didn't bury the dog with the collar right actually these are these i've heard of stuff like like they make cat bulls like this or Apologize to my hamster.
I'm sorry, Splunkaboo.
I'm sorry.
Like, they make cat bowls like this where the cat, like, it reacts to the chip in them and so that each cat can only eat their own food.
I think anyone's inside?
I don't think so.
They wouldn't have boarded it up if they were going to stay in.
Did they weigh in yet?
Doors locked up tight.
Too heavy to force it without making a whole lot or look at Hamtaro the same way I wasn't wrong though I ain't seeing it you think maybe someone's still inside nah we'd have heard from him by now all the racket we're making but whoever was here did a pretty good job fortifying it nice place to hold up we can just figure out how to get in hey are you holding up man Lee I appreciate the interest but I don't think talking about my feelings right now is gonna help us get inside this house okay maybe you should have a look around see what you can find okay time to dig up the dog this is so sad i don't want to do this i really don't want to do this though do you have a chip in your collar too meinto
cat chips did they come in ranch flavor wait what did he say looks like something was buried here yeah the dog he's not in the house is he empty Oh, that would have been too easy.
Oh, oh, we're doing squats.
Okay, we got to find something to use to dig it up, I guess.
But where?
I didn't see anything like a...
Oh, there it is.
The shovel is never not useful.
Yeah, Chuck had the shovel!
Chuck had the shovel Okay I could we could have used our hands Be careful Digging up dead things isn't what it used to be You know what I mean Zombie dog From the grave arises Do we ever expect Okay maybe we don't get so close to it If we think it's a zombie dog
Stay away Nothing Go over and sit with Chris Don't over Okay Yeah but I want to just do what I say okay yeah oh no we're trying to save your feelings oh oh god the smell he you don't have to imagine it
uh I don't think that thing is dead oh my god must have belonged to someone well of course
can't get it off okay that is not cool are you okay I'm fine honey it's just the smell are you sure you're I said I'm fine okay
can we re-burry it I don't beat that anymore I'm done digging up dead dogs for today.
I think we should re-burry him, no!
Everyone hated that.
There goes
nothing.
Yes!
God damn!
You see anything in there?
No.
Looks like it's been empty a while.
Nice.
Uh-oh.
It's getting louder.
Whatever you're gonna do, do it fast.
Okay, let me see if I can reach up in there.
Be careful, man.
Okay.
Uh-oh, there's a lot of noise.
It's no good.
I can't get it.
Here, let me try.
I think I can...
Oh!
Clem!
What do you see?
Clem, what do you see in there?
Clem?
She just crawled in so fast!
Look at...
She's so smart.
Good job, Clem.
Yeah, way to go.
I did good, right?
Yes, you did.
You did good.
Can we maybe have this conversation inside?
Yeah, Clem!
She didn't even like, she went in with the mission and she accomplished it as quickly as she did it.
It was clean.
It was great.
Also, Ben trying to be helpful.
It's too late for that.
What if Clem had died, we never would have been able to get inside.
Stupid.
Shut the door?
Thank you.
Wow, nice place.
Sorry, sorry.
No, it's okay.
I'm good.
Clem is worth 1,000 bends.
Thanks, babe.
I don't think he's going to make it.
Oh, that's a dog.
I thought that was like an alien child.
The rat person and their family.
When were you going to tell us about the radio?
I didn't.
What?
That it's working.
That there's someone else on the other end of that thing.
You didn't think that might have been worth sharing with the rest of us?
I only found out.
I was going to tell you.
Kenny and I only found out yesterday.
I was honest.
So both of you were keeping it from the rest of us.
Who gives a shit about the damn radio?
I'm more worried about whoever it was out there ringing that bell and bringing the dead down on top of us.
It's like they didn't want us to make it to the river.
What makes you think it's not the same person?
was close enough to see us in the street and you can see anyone else other than the guy in the bell tower.
Because that doesn't make a lick of damn sense.
Why would they bring out the dead like that and then try to warn us about it?
How much sense does anything make anymore?
In case you haven't noticed, there's a lot of twisted folks out there they're stalking us.
Whoever it was, seems like they're following us.
But Ben's sleep at the doghouse.
All the more reason to get on a damn boat where we can't be followed.
going back out there anytime soon.
Omeed needs to rest.
Let's rest up.
I think everybody just needs to rest up.
I think we could all use a little time to rest up and gather our thoughts, Kiki.
At least until those walkers outside wander off and Omeed's feeling better.
He best feel better quick.
I ain't gonna wait around here too long.
Kenny, there's no need to be such a jerk anymore.
Your family's dead.
Please seem secure at least.
I'll feel better when we know that for sure.
to check the whole house yes all right fine you and me you'll take the upstairs didn't even consider looking for Chuck Chuck make sure you check every door understand okay I mean such logic I mean yeah can I help what if there's another locked door look how excited she is I think you've been helpful enough for one day kiddo why don't you just see if Kristen Oh me need anything okay okay you can't crawl through every door little Clem Who's Chuck?
Well, let's examine the cabinets.
The dog food.
They're all empty.
I think this place is clear.
For real, though.
Like, even the dog food is empty.
This place has been...
Like, picked apart.
I hope we never get desperate enough for food that this starts looking appetizing.
So...
When I was a weird...
Whisp.
I'm not that hungry.
Signs I need to finish checking the downstairs.
I had dogs.
And they had a treat called popcorn.
But like, why would you name it that?
Nothing.
Water's off.
Why would you name it something that sounds so delicious?
And not expect me to eat it.
No power.
Yeah, like popcorn, but popcorn.
My dog, Walter!
This is so sad.
This is why you're into stale popcorn.
It might be.
Even the fridge is empty.
All cleaned out.
Yeah, like they didn't die here.
They like took everything and...
Were moonwalking?
They took everything and ran after Walter died.
There's a zombie in the clock.
Must have stopped working a while ago.
Whoever cleared this place out left behind two bottles of whiskey.
Looks like someone didn't have their priorities straight.
How's it coming?
I'm looking!
take one probably not the best idea right now never mind I need to stay frosty frosty looks expensive and heavy doubt any looters would be able to hold that thing too far now I want to make puppy chow no don't eat don't eat dog food hello hey guys how's the house looking not done searching the first floor yet but so far so good About this boat plan.
What do you guys think about this plan at Kinney's?
The guy's losing it.
Look, Lee, I know he's your friend and all.
But you need to be careful.
That man is on the edge.
And I don't know if I want to be around when he goes over it.
Kinney's solid.
It's just been through a lot.
That's all.
I hope you're right.
For all our sakes.
You and your core and obsession.
Puppy Chow is muddy buddies.
Wait, you guys are just saying things.
this point i don't know at all what you're saying how's that couch treating you omead leg feeling better yet i'm all right oh feel you it does not look all right it does not look all right this house was a hell of a stroke of luck i like it a lot better when we know for sure it's safe i'll make sure but right now it feels like just the break we need it maybe our luck's starting to turn around i'd like to believe that really chocolate pizza butter checks i think sit tight I'll keep checking the first floor to make sure it's safe.
Yeah.
Thanks, Lee.
You're welcome.
How about Clem?
Hold it up, okay?
I hope this house is safe.
Have you checked all the rooms to make sure?
I'm working on it.
No, but I'll take care of it.
Yeah, maybe we should go grab the shovel.
So that we know that we have a little weapon, you know?
Let's check this room.
Oh.
Oh, we have a gun.
That's true.
Jesus!
Oh, my God.
It's a mop.
What?
What happened?
It's nothing.
Just nothing.
Okay.
That's like...
Wait, so it's a storage closet?
Because it's like the biggest storage closet.
The doors are humongous.
I think I saw another door.
Yeah, another door over here.
We got some paintings.
Oh!
Not exactly my style.
Spooky.
We have two doors.
Let's open the small one first.
Ah!
Ha!
Bathroom.
Nothing hiding in here.
Okay, but check for...
medical supplies.
Just one more to check.
Oh, the dog.
Rich person house.
I know.
This place is fancy.
Huh?
Another closet.
That's the last room.
Looks like downstairs is secure.
Okay.
Well, the place ain't got much.
We should be okay here for a while.
At least until it quits down outside.
Good.
Thanks.
Amid?
Is he okay?
Are you alive?
No.
But I'm really worried his leg might have gotten infected.
Don't suppose he turned up any meds while you were poking around.
I didn't even look!
Just dog food.
And there's some whiskey in the back.
Wait, you could do that.
Pour that on the wound, Renault?
Isn't that alcohol?
She knows who the man on her radio is.
It's okay, honey.
You can tell us.
Who is he?
What does he want?
We want answers, Clementine!
We want answers!
Go ahead, Clem.
It's okay.
You're not in any trouble.
It's just a friend.
I don't think he wants to hurt us.
What has he been saying to you?
What have you been saying to him?
Oh, I told him I was trying to find my parents and that they were in Savannah.
He really seems nice.
I think he wants to help me find them.
Clementine, honey, trust me.
That's not what he wants.
He...
Lee?
Uh-oh.
Yes, Ben?
Something that...
Lee, you need to get up here now.
What's wrong?
It's Kenny.
Kenny?
Wait, is this...
Kenny said he thought he heard something up there.
Went to go look.
He's up there?
No, Kenny's alive.
I can't get him to come down.
Kenny, say something.
Stay here.
Oh.
Oh, Kenny?
Kenny?
Oh.
I hear flies.
Kenny?
Wait, what's wrong with him?
Oh, he's alive.
Okay.
Kenny?
You okay, man?
What's wrong?
I hear- Oh, Jesus.
What the hell is that?
What is this?
Oh.
What?
I was gonna say it looks like duck.
Oh my god, no.
She's like starved up here.
Guess he must have been hiding out up here.
Starved to death.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know if I can, Lee.
Couldn't do it before.
Can't do it now.
I mean...
Let's just leave.
We don't have to do this right now.
could just maybe we should just get out of here you can't hurt anyone yeah you can't even stand up walk away i don't know if i can do that either i guess we could i mean like i can't i can't do anything you can give the gun to kenny no way when you say kenny it sounds like a south park character kenny poor kid must have tried to hide out of here until he starved to death This could have been clean time.
Oh, don't say that.
Don't say that.
I could shoot him.
I could bash him.
I could stomp him.
Oh my gosh.
Pick your poison, kid.
Wait, if I get so close, is he gonna grab me?
He doesn't even have the strength.
Kid.
Why did he take off his clothes?
I don't understand.
Don't waste ammo.
I agree.
I think we're going to have to stomp him like a little bug.
Um.
It's hot in the attic.
Okay, that's fair.
I don't like the noises it's making.
Okay, let's just bash him in.
Well, Kenny, we could only give him the but we're gonna not we're not gonna we're gonna conserve ammo nice and easy okay oh my god you chose to do it yourself we should bury him i'll take care of it oh we put so much on ourselves you know like lee takes on so much
like everyone is going through it but so is lee You know, it's so sad
He's very supportive he is he's a good guy
Oh, I guess it's oh he's gonna be with this dog
So sad
look at boy okay if you didn't get a good enough view before i suppose it's so sad
it is with this puppy
oh i gotta do it myself okay Come on.
They did this back in ancient times, burying the owner and dog together.
Why do I have to keep doing it?
I don't understand.
Is she disappointed?
But she'll close the door on.
Oh my gosh.
I'll just keep going.
Okay.
Just sad.
Cover his sock.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
That was the most horror thing that has happened.
That's a real person.
That was...
Who are you?
What the hell do you want from us?
Lee, what's going on?
Like, the most horror thing that happened this entire game.
someone was watching someone standing there by the fence watching us a walker no too fast took off like a bat out of hell when i spotted him was it a man or a woman didn't get a good enough look what does it matter i'm wondering if it's the same guy who's been following us the guy on the radio
kenny kenny i'm fine i just i'm fine what's all the ruckus I wonder if we had let Kenny do it I can't be sure it ran off before I could get a good look you know I don't like this one bit and then had his little his like a more sense of peace walkers are one thing but the thought of someone out there actually stalking us alright that's it we've stuck around here long enough it's time to get back on track time to get down to the river and find ourselves a boat I don't know if O'Mead's well enough to move well he better get ready because I'm going down to River Street right now wait let's yeah as soon as she's ready to go supplies supplies supplies we only check the house to make sure it's secure we didn't really toss the place we're low on food water meds ammo we should make sure we would have meds before we move out we would have meds if someone I'm done with this house we came to this city to find the boat and that's just what I'm gonna do maybe it's not such a idea to check the place
I said I'm done with this house deserved
we can do both Kenny you take one last look around a place grab anything that looks useful while me and Kenny go down to the river to get us a boat oh wait can't I come my mom and dad can't be far now maybe we can look for them on the to the river stay here and help i think it'd be best if you stayed here with ben i need you to watch out for omead and krista help them get ready to move out you said i'm supposed to always stay close to you i know it's just this once sometimes we all have to put aside what we want for the good of the group hey don't worry i'll be back before you know it okay no way wait oh no somebody's gonna who's gonna die then we'll head out omead's gonna die Omid's gonna turn into a zombie.
Oh god, somebody's gonna die.
We're gonna die.
Who's gonna die?
So you're just gonna leave me on the bench here?
Um, you're not reliable.
No offense, Ben.
Uh, keep an eye.
I'm worried about Omid.
He's in bad shape.
I need you to stay here.
Yeah.
Keep an eye on him.
He's got Krista for that.
If it comes down to it, I can't rely on Krista to do what has to be done.
Now with Clementine in the same house.
You understand what I'm saying?
You have not proved yourself to be reliable.
Oh, we're counting on you.
You can count on me.
When have we been able to count on you all those other times that we needed to count on you?
Ben!
Counting on Ben infected.
Creepy.
Creepy, creepy, creepy.
Sorry, guys.
I'm gonna blow my nose.
Hopefully, there's no QTEs.
Don't mute!
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, fine.
Ben lied as easily as he breathed.
Maybe he's turning over a new leaf.
In the one hour that we were in that home.
Keep an eye out for Chuck.
Keep your eye out for Chuck.
You might be waiting for us around here.
Yeah.
Yeah, sure.
Okay, Kenny, I know you don't care about Chuck.
Chuck at all.
Son of a bitch.
That bastard's fucking with us again.
It's another trap.
No, listen.
That's not the same bell as before.
This one's further off.
Whatever it is, it's gonna get the dead moving over there.
I'd count on Minto mental math before I count on Ben.
Uh oh.
Oh, they're going that way.
Why is she crawling?
What in the hell is going on?
Why are there posters for mosquitoes?
Did they think the virus spread through mosquitoes?
Uh, maybe they're doing us a favor, yeah.
The person ringing that bell might be doing us a favor.
She got that doll dinner.
I'll ring their motherfucking bell for them.
Good one.
Come on, keep up, Krista.
Wait, Krista's the other lady's name.
She just looks like a Christine or something.
Keep up!
Jessica.
Still nothing moving behind us.
think we're oh my god what's wrong what is it the boats there's no boats there's got to be a boat there's got to be there was one right there um oh shoot uh kenny man i don't think so maybe we need to come up with a new plan this is the plan it's the only one we've got there's one right Pissing on it in front of everyone like you did back at the house ain't exactly helping screw you.
I ain't giving up that easy Kenny Kenny dear.
It's time to What what about this one right there?
Oh god.
Oh no, it's flooded.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no.
Oh no This one might still be salvageable.
Oh Nope Kenny get a grip this boy boat is totally fun it's aft oh yeah know a lot about boats do you tell you what if i ever need an expert opinion on american history i'll be sure to ask but how about you leave the nautical shit to me hey you don't make fun of my career my hobbies kenny i'll check it out you look further along the waterfront maybe there's something at the other end the poor guy this one should split up too far we don't have to see that telescope you can see all the way Life is spiraling.
See what you can find.
Okay, Kenny, those cost money.
Unfortunately, even though the world is...
is... is... is...
F to hell.
We...
Oh my god.
Whoa!
We still have to pay money.
We're still...
Keep out.
Wait, what was this one?
The boards.
Got a quarter.
Maybe we kept the 67 cents.
Oh, we really just walked all the way up there.
Looks like the whole city has been boarded up for all the good it did.
What was there?
Ah!
I think here, here, here.
We'll get some money.
It's an old cash register.
That much use these days.
Except for when we have to pay for that thing.
An abandoned newsstand.
Okay.
A-A-J.
What the hell are these markings?
Okay, so I kind of know some of this.
So I watched something recently about, like, hurricanes, and how they would, like, when they went and checked the houses for people, they would put markings like this.
So it would be, like, two people, probably one dead, one alive.
or stuff like that is kind of what the what the markings are like yeah yeah today I learned yeah is this meant to be some kind of warning or do something like this yeah this is kind of metal I like this part
I didn't think they were still alive.
Are these all bodies?
Holy wow.
I'm not going to shoot it.
That's crazy.
Raven, oh no.
I don't want to go back.
Oh my gosh, there's one down here too.
If I get close enough, will they grab me?
No.
This is so cool!
Oh, there's a guy here too!
Hey, hey, hi!
Oh,
there's more markings here.
So this one...
Oh, wait.
Let's see.
Could be military tags, but what do they mean?
Oh.
I don't know what the numbers are anymore.
But, but I'm not wrong for like the...
Well, the hurricane stuff.
That is what they did.
Okay, it doesn't seem there's any...
Is this a...
No?
Okay.
The numbers!
What did I mean?
But also, there's like 8 AJ.
That could be...
Uh, like the...
The person that...
I don't know.
I was gonna say the initials of the person that...
Checked the place?
But...
I don't know.
You are right about the numbers.
I am!
Stay out.
That's a lot of bodies.
Great.
Needs a quarter to one.
I knew it.
Why couldn't we get the quarter before?
Maybe the officer's ID.
Ah, maybe, maybe, maybe.
Right?
Oh.
I bet Kenny looted whatever his name's body and took the 67 cents I think Kenny took it number knowledge rocks us like hurricane look at the truck someone must have been trying to back their boat into the water I am.
Larry.
Kenny, you got a quarter?
Don't have a lot of use for small change these days.
Maybe you can find one on the street somewhere.
Okay.
I'll check under the dumpster.
Or I didn't look this way.
What's over here?
Oh, newspaper machine maybe?
Looks like it's still intact.
Oh, you can do it.
Locked.
Figures.
Traded for some bottle caps.
Wow.
Looks like this thing has been stripped clean.
Survival of the Minties.
Wow.
Wait, they have trolleys in Savannah.
So cute.
I want to ride one.
Oh, I see how you are.
I see the rail now.
I want to ride one.
I've always wanted to ride like a street trolley before.
Cash your counter.
I don't think there was anything on the counter.
Let's go check the alleyway.
There's gotta be a reason we can go through here.
No?
Right?
Check the dumpster?
Nothing, really?
Okay.
What state does this take place in?
This takes place in Georgia.
Always been too shy to ask for birthday wishes from anyone in previous years.
Good op.
Doing it for the first time in six years.
Happy birthday, Korofi!
Happy, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
You think I have to kill this guy to search his butt?
Better not.
Oh.
Okay, you're right.
I was right the first time.
Can I search your butt?
This guy's gotta have a quarter in the back pocket.
Where else can I look?
Um...
down this way we didn't really look anything no okay oh wait I should probably stick close to Kenny it's too dangerous out here I just saw I thought I saw someone standing over there oh wait I do I think that's a zombo right there you see oh my head's kind of blocking it I think that's a zombo right there there's something very classic Resident Evil 2 about this entire you know I'm really liking it.
Yeah, it's cool.
G-VAN!
Oh, good.
We can bash the newspaper.
A quarter.
Let's go.
Silent Hill with all the fog.
New Silent Hill soon.
I saw some people getting early access to it.
And I'm avoiding I'm like, oh my gosh, I have to avoid everything.
I have to avoid watching them play.
I'm so excited, though.
Fuck!
What?
What's up with the boat?
It ain't gonna work.
Holes cracked beneath the waterline, plus someone stripped out the battery.
Uh-huh.
You can't fix it?
Oh, the battery?
Where are you gonna...
What are you gonna do with the battery?
What the hell is that?
A fate worse than death.
That's so messed up.
Okay.
We got this building.
How do we know?
You took one glance at it.
No sign of any boats down there.
Watch there be one single boat.
But it's going to belong to someone.
Plenty of ducks.
No boats.
There wouldn't be a...
Just a boat.
Oh, I guess the sunken boat.
Up river.
What if we looked over and there's Kenny?
Oh.
What the hell?
Wait, what am I seeing?
Oh my gosh, Spider-Man.
Oh my god.
Get down.
I didn't get to observe everything, but that's okay.
Why the hell are we hiding?
Someone came down from that building at the end of the street.
Where'd he go?
So I'm running to that news.
Yeah, he's right there.
Could be our bell ringer.
How about we go find out?
Ambush.
Yeah, sounds like a plan.
Sounds like a plan.
Let's go do it.
Okay, you head up the middle of the street.
I'll go around the side.
He's kind of got a weapon, though, but we have a gun.
Come up on him quiet.
Take him by surprise.
All right, let's go.
Yeah.
We just want to talk to this guy.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, we're going to talk.
Oh, I'm going to talk.
Okay, what's the plan?
What are we doing?
Sneaking mission?
Hello?
Trying to get some magazines?
Oh, nobody's here.
Oh, how'd he do that?
Oh, it's a kid.
Oh, ow!
Oops.
I was too slow.
Hey!
No!
Him!
Clem?
Please, don't hurt him.
A girl?
Can't, uh, I don't know.
Hello.
Well, not a kid.
It looked so small.
You're not from Crawford.
Gasp.
Uh, you're not the guy on the radio?
Crawford?
What the hell are you talking about?
Alire.
Kenny, Kenny, put the gun down.
Kenny, put the gun down.
Kenny, Kenny, Kenny, don't.
Kenny, don't.
Oh my god.
No, he's with us.
Yeah, but he's kind of stupid.
We apologize for his...
Kenny, Kenny, we said no.
Who the hell are you people?
We're just coming.
Everyone calm down.
Everyone just calm down.
down once she tells me who the fuck she is the name's Molly Molly I'm Lee this is Kenny and Clementine we're not looking for any trouble yeah hi hi she's so cute you guys really aren't from Crawford are you what is Crawford I don't even know what that is everything beyond that barricade oh what the hell happened here oh I Are they like the crazy like...
Are you sure you want to know?
They created like some crazy faction.
When everything started going to shit, some people got together and sealed off that whole neighborhood.
Folks willing to do anything to stay alive.
Stop the dead getting in.
I try to avoid them.
Why?
Let's just say they have a zero tolerance policy for anyone who won't or can't live by their rules.
So how'd you know we weren't them?
the smell because there are no children in crawford not anymore well who's been ringing the bells who's been ringing those bells all over town yeah yeah that would be me oh i knew it lee i knew she was the one who's been following us fucking with us hey get that finger out of my face kenny chill before i jam it straight up your ass i haven't been following you i don't even know who the hell you people are calm down kenny the voice on the radio she does look like the one that The first church.
Whoever you are, ringing those bells this morning nearly got us all killed.
Yeah.
Raised the dead all around us.
That's the idea, genius.
It's how I get around.
I ring a bell in one neighborhood to attract the local geeks towards it.
Lies me some time to scavenge the areas they cleared out.
Geeks.
Is that what you call them?
Yeah.
You know, like at the carnival, bellied anything, alive or dead.
What?
I thought...
Wait, what?
Doesn't take much to outsmart the dead.
A bunch of dumbasses.
You just gotta move fast.
She's so cool.
before they start to wander back again what's the oh wait why no children no children why not I'm no children no elderly no one with an advanced medical condition basically no one who might be a burden on the community Crawford's all about the survival of the fittest that's how they survive the rest of the world went to shit around but but you're gonna eventually not have survival of the Everyone's gonna get old with no kids.
What exactly did Crawford do with all these burdens?
What happened to them?
Well, you met some of them already.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Yeah, anyone who got sick, anyone too old, anyone they figured wasn't strong enough to survive.
To them, those people were just mouths to feed.
A drain on their precious resources.
I'd live.
How do you know all this?
Everyone in Savannah knew.
What was going on inside Crawford got passed around like a ghost story.
Except this one was true.
If I were alive, I mean, I would live.
Probably.
But yeah, I'm a ghost anyway.
I'm going to ask you people again.
You're not from Crawford, so who the hell are you?
What are you doing here?
We were trying to get a boat.
I came down here looking for a ball, hoping to get our people out of here and find someplace safe.
Yeah, good luck with that.
Anyone with a boat took it out of here as soon as people started eating each other.
Any of that got left behind, Crawford stripped him for parts.
Hours too.
There's gotta be something.
If there was, do you think I'd still be here?
I've been over every inch of this city.
This whole place is- Yeah, it's funny if they realize kids are important after they get told to have them.
God damn it.
Fuck!
Hey, moron.
You want to keep your voice down?
Caddy, shh!
Shit.
Since you're not getting on any boat, I'd advise you folks to go back to where you came from before...
No.
Oh, no!
Great!
Just wait.
No!
Oh, I was trying to say who's the girl Spider-Man earlier.
I think it's Gwen.
That's who she reminds me of.
Isn't there another way back to the house?
Molly, is there a...
Molly's out?
Molly...
Molly is part...
Hey!
You're just gonna leave us here?
Sorry, I must have missed that part of our conversation where you became my problem.
Yeah!
Please!
Yeah, give her the puppy dog eyes.
Come on!
Make it fast!
Okay.
Oh my god.
They're hobbling over here.
They're so slow!
Hurry!
There's slow little guys.
Me, come on.
One good jump.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Oh, it's just like before.
Oh my god, no.
No!
It's just like before.
I'm gonna push the dumpster, but I'm gonna do it with no sense of urgency.
And we're gonna run.
Eh, oh.
Oh no!
It's the girl that's...
crawling come on Lee get your ass out of there I guess we're going in the sewer um here use that to hide open she's giving us her weapon her climbing pick oh cute cute cute cute cute cute cute cute cute cute cute cute cute cute cute did he just fall oh there was a last Okay,
good.
I thought they would just fall in.
Oh, they do.
They do just fall in.
She really went.
I missed the part where that's my problem.
She is Spider-Man!
Clementine, can you hear me?
If you can hear me, just get back to the house, okay?
I'll meet you there.
Oh.
Sewer episode?
Shit.
They're going back now.
Sewer level.
It's a zombie game, all right.
Wait, uh, uh, uh, this way?
Okay, here we go.
We gonna get teenage mutant ninja turtles.
Okay, we have that way.
All right, that's the way we gotta go.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
I thought the game froze on me for a second.
Yeah, what happened to the climbing pick?
We have our gun, but I think that's the only thing we've got.
Why did he get...
Rats!
No!
Dead rats!
Half eaten sewer rats.
Walkers must be down here too.
I can pick it up.
Why would I do that?
Last thing I need is some god-awful disease.
Oh, I do have the pick.
You can see it in my inventory.
Open the passageway.
I hear...
I hear it.
I hear something.
Close.
It's a drainage pipe.
There's a sound.
They sound so close.
Oh, I don't like the angle.
Um, wasn't it the first...
Yeah, wasn't it the first episode of The Walking Dead where they covered themselves in, like, the grossness and, uh, slip through the dead that way?
Oh, what is this?
What is this gonna do?
What's the park gonna do?
They did that at some point.
Yeah, right.
Lentil, welcome back.
Thank you so much.
What happens if I do...
What's...
What's this park do?
Looks like some kind of drainage pipe.
Can we flush them out?
Turn it left.
Wait, lefty Lucy.
Righty tidy.
Righty.
Oh, oh.
Dang it.
Good thing I'm out here and not in there.
It seems loose.
Oh!
Shit.
Stop talking to yourself, maybe?
Oh my gosh.
The controls.
Open up.
Never mind.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Nice.
Where are we?
Oh, wait.
We just made a little loop.
So then we use it on this.
But what are they doing over here?
Oh my gosh.
That was so scary.
It started turning red because the guy was going to notice me.
Okay.
tidy what is this oh and then if we go crawl back into the okay we go crawl back into the hole enter enter enter enter enter enter enter enter hurry okay it distracts them we learned from this guy oh my gosh why is it red like they're gonna notice me oh it's scary It's so scary.
Is that all of them?
It is.
Oh, but except her.
But I guess it's fine.
Wait, I don't like this part.
It's so scary.
Okay, I'm going.
Chuck!
You must have tried to hide out down here.
Poor bastard.
No bullets.
You must have saved the last one for yourself.
Oh, Chuck!
I think we can get her.
Sorry, oh my god, this scared the heck out of me.
Oh, damn it, damn it, damn it.
Oh, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
This game is suddenly turning so scary.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Okay.
Everything's fine.
Phew.
I was even too, I was too panicked to even say anything.
Holy moly.
Gosh.
Those bars are way too solid.
That was so scary.
Okay.
To the left or to the, anything to the left?
Nope, it's the wall.
Okay.
Pick up the broken ladder.
No way I could pick that up on my own.
Uh, look at the bro.
Looks like somebody saw the damn thing off.
That's messed up!
Oh, I see, is that a door right there?
It did go down to him!
Jump scare.
Can I grab it?
Maybe with the thing?
Be careful.
There's a hole there.
What the hell?
Is this a door?
I like how we can pick up the door.
Lot.
Fucking perfect.
Okay, of course it doesn't work.
Uh-oh, I think we're heading into Crawford, you guys.
I think this is gonna go to Crawford.
I don't think this goes home.
Uh-oh, maybe we should cover it back up.
Fallout shelter.
We're playing Fallout.
know must have been one of those old nuclear fallout shelters there's tons of food in here wonder if someone's living down here look at all this it's enough to keep people alive for months yeah guys i'm so sorry i have to go to the little ghosty's room so before we go through the door
I'm going to go do that.
Right quick.
Little cliffhanger for you guys.
Give me one second.
I'm so sorry.
Chuck was so close.
I know.
Oh, I didn't think Chuck would...
Well, I don't know.
I don't know.
Okay, BRB.
Okay, I'm back.
Sorry about that.
Okie dokie.
Resume.
Alright, here we go.
everybody so blue thank you for all the thank you for the summertime thank you thank you thank you all righty oh oh oh oh that's awkward uh i don't want any trouble it's all right it's okay i love how it's just like i could ask the same neither do we but which is why you'd do well to turn around and leave right now look I'm sorry we barged into their home I'll just be going you can't let him leave he's from Crawford if he goes back there and they find out we're down here are you from Crawford they don't lie to me I know where else can he be from everywhere else around here I'm not from around here I'm from Athens grew up in Macon yeah yeah yeah sister I have a brother in Macon you were there how was it as bad as here yeah I'm You can't trust him,
Vernon.
You can't let him leave.
What do you want me to do?
Shoot him in the head?
Oh, look, he's shaking!
Be more of a mercy than anyone from Crawford ever showed us.
Think, Vernon.
What do you think they'll do if they find out we're down here?
Vernon, don't do it.
Don't do it, Vernon.
Damn it.
You're right.
I'm sorry.
I'm not from Crawford.
Can't take the risk.
I'm not from Crawford, but I saw what they did up there.
It made me sick.
Yeah, I've tried.
I'm reasoning.
I don't think you are either.
I think you're a good man.
Yeah, Vernon.
Oh.
Keep back or I swear I'll shoot.
Uh, uh, uh.
I told you he's lying.
He is one of them.
Kill him before he killed us.
I didn't think he would do it.
I didn't think he, I didn't think he would do it.
Oh, I have to go through this all over again.
Uh, I don't want any trouble.
All right.
We'll do the same thing as before.
I don't want any trouble.
Neither do we.
why you'd do well to turn around and leave right now look i'm sorry i got it right but didn't grab okay i'll just be going you can't let him leave i thought i didn't think i should grab it i thought he would like he would see that i was being peaceful don't like to taste i know where else can he be from i'm not from around here i'm not from around here i'm from athens grew up in bacon bacon bacon i have a brother in mnh you were there how was it as bad as here I'm sorry You can't trust him,
Vernon You can't let him leave What do you want me to do?
Shoot him in the head Why not?
Be more of a mercy than anyone from Crawford ever showed us Before I'd live What do you think they'll do if they find out we're down here Right under their feet?
Damn it, you're right I'm not from Crawford I love how you can threaten them Like that's a good idea I'm not from Crawford But I saw what they did up there Made me sick I'm not like them And I don't think you are either Yeah man yeah keep back or i swear i'll shoot okay i'm gonna grab your gun now it's all right it's okay fernan what the hell are you doing fernan relax i'm not here to hurt you we just took your gun you're really not from crawford we just we just we just yoinked that from you put it in my back started sealing up the place you know started weeding out the sick and the old so their perfect survivor society wouldn't be threatened no room for weakness or vulnerability in their little master race you don't look that old so you're sick we're sick we're all members of a cancer survivors group that used to meet here at the hospital that's so sad we're in remission but that wasn't good enough for crawford they'd already rounded up five of us before the rest has managed to hole
up and hide from him down here.
This old basement's been abandoned for years.
They're in provision!
What is this?
The morgue?
Yeah.
Irony's always high on my list when I'm looking for a place to survive.
I'm bunk beds.
How did you find your way down here?
Uh, walkers.
A few of us got boxed in by walkers up on the street.
Came down here trying to get away.
I was honest.
Now I just want to get out of here.
Get back to my own people.
Yeah.
system you came through runs all over the city it'll take you wherever you want to go uh can you show me the way back those sewers are like a damn maze any chance you could help me find my way back look i'd like to help you but we've all got our own problems yeah group are sick and need constant care and i'm the only doctor here oh besides why should we help you okay rude i have to get back to clementine look sorry if i scared you i just want to get back to my back to Clementine wait she's your daughter yes yeah she's probably already wondering where I am Vernon we can't have that can we what the hell are you doing she's my adopted daughter I had a daughter too lost her in the first days I'll be damned if I'll just sit back and let that happen to someone else we need you here don't worry now be back before you know it let's go see your daughter burn it oh oh they're already saying their goodbyes is he gonna die everyone else here will die
suddenly the frame rate got so bad it's not your daughter she is my adopted daughter oh clementine oh wow we're already We're already back?
That was so fast.
Molly?
Hi, Molly.
Oh, hey.
You made it back.
Who's this?
I don't know.
He didn't tell you about me?
Understandable, I guess.
I'm the one who put that beating on him when he tried to jump me back at the river.
Who's the fossil?
Where's Clementine?
She's around here somewhere.
Relax.
I got her and Kenny both back safely.
You're welcome, by the way.
interaction why are we supposed to tell him about you we don't know who you are
back off chat Molly's mind dang you guys already fighting over her Lee thank God you're back oh oh oh me it's oh me it's gotten worse I forgot his name we have a man wounded who's this he's a doctor he's a doctor oh thank god could you take a look at him you have to help us hey please yeah say please guys see what I can do take me to them we have no medical supplies and it's like kind of not great why did Vernon come all the way I know right what is that plushie it's kind of creepy Omead,
honey.
You're gonna be all right.
Lee brought a doctor.
Omead?
All right, let's take a look at it.
I work better without an audience.
Why don't you go find your little girl?
He's gonna kill him.
Clementine?
Clementine, it's Clementine.
Where are you?
Clementine, you in here?
Where is she?
What's in the cabinet?
Clementine's drawing!
Clem, you in here?
She wouldn't hide from us, would she?
Minus two.
It was good.
Shut up.
Clem's drawings.
Where is she?
Why does she draw that?
Why?
Oh, gosh.
We don't need just doctors.
We need therapists.
Oh, my gosh.
Bathroom?
Are you in there?
Oh, me.
Did we hear by W.D.
Dennis too.
I like him too.
Clem?
Where?
Where is she?
Oh, the shadow kind of scared me.
Hello?
Clem?
Oh, who are you?
Oh, Molly.
What are you doing?
Oh, you know, just poking around.
You won't find anything.
We already searched the place.
You'd be surprised what people miss.
Trust me, I've been doing this for a while.
It's Ben, so I wouldn't blink.
Yeah, I wouldn't.
Where's Clementine?
Don't ask me.
I'm not her keeper.
Hey, do I look like I'm in the mood to be jerked around?
Where did she go?
Last I saw she was downstairs with your redneck friend and that college kid who hangs around with him.
Why don't you go bug them?
Why is the music getting so intense?
I don't care about that.
I just want to find Clementine.
Okay, okay.
Alright, we'll go downstairs.
We'll go.
Oh, this is the bathroom.
There's an Easter egg here.
Should I go back in?
Wait, let's look through the hallway window real quick.
She's not outside, right?
Don't see her out there.
We're, like, really freaking out, though.
We're, like, really, really freaking out after you.
What else is in here, anyway?
Molly?
Molly!
I told you, that girl isn't with me.
Go ask your buddies and quit bothering me.
Stop yelling at me!
maybe in the drawers then Clementine no sign of her in here okay I don't know what the Easter egg is but that's okay you let me instead Molly you guys okay we're not going to go in there we'll go downstairs because that's where she said she was Clementine come out Please!
Are we okay?
Kenny?
Oh, hey, you made it back.
Good job.
What the hell do you think you're doing?
What does it look like?
Where'd you get the bottle?
It was on the table.
Found it.
You want to throw down again like back on the train?
Because I fight better when I'm shit-faced.
Kenny, come on.
Give me that.
Give me the bottle, Kenny.
Give me the damn bottle.
Give me the bottle, Ken.
Get the fuck away from me.
Kenny!
Getting wasted's not going to help anyone.
Yeah?
Well, what is?
We are fucked.
Molly said there's not a single boat left in Savannah.
Yeah?
No way out.
We got walkers all around us.
That crazy fuck on the radio messing with us.
Hell, if now ain't the time for a drink?
But bed's just sitting there.
Ben don't do it.
Ben, take it from him.
Take it from him, Ben.
Where is Clementine?
Have either of you seen Clementine?
Damn to final.
Gotta be around here somewhere.
Ben, how did Clementine sneak out of the house?
Hey, don't put all that on me.
Omid took a turn for the worse, and Krista asked me to help.
I'm sorry.
I'm doing the best I can here.
You're not doing...
She was frantic, and things got kind of crazy.
That's not good enough.
I told Clementine to stay put.
What else could I do?
That's not good enough.
Whatever.
Oh!
Don't give me that whatever shit.
Just tell me where she is.
I think she went out to play in the backyard.
On her own.
With no one watching her?
Man, will you get off my back?
Oh my god.
You literally said that there's somebody watching us!
And you said that she's fine out there!
Clementine?
Oh my god!
She's gotta be in here.
She's in here.
Door's covered in pines.
Don't think anyone came in through there.
Okay.
Everything is still the same there.
But I'm in a being totally useless challenge if I have voted in this bed.
She's in the doghouse?
She's not...
in the doghouse oh my god we're gonna find like something of hers on the ground oh my god oh my god oh my god she's in the bushes it's we're done playing weasel come on out did i look at everything out here
oh whoops Don't think anyone came in through there.
Uh...
Oh, what were you doing in there?
What were you doing in there?
Exploring?
And look!
Look what I found!
Yeah?
How'd you get in there?
What?
Cool.
Oh!
No way!
She found a boat!
Holy shit.
Swear.
Oh, sorry.
I should have said, whoa.
You can thank Clementine, the best character.
Best character, Clementine.
She's... she's... she's gotten us through so much.
Oh my god!
But how do we get it to the water?
Uh-oh, is he alive?
Omid?
Clem's the real MVP.
She's the goat.
She's the best of all time.
She's the boat!
One Clementine is worth 2,000 beds.
Uh, how's Omid doing?
Omid's doing okay?
As well as can be expected under the circumstances.
I did what I could for you.
Minus two that?
That was good!
That was a real infection.
Without antibiotics, I...
Will you quit pacing?
You're making everyone nervous.
Why are you even still here?
I'm just walking.
Hey, if your friend really can get that boat working, you're taking me with you as payment for saving your asses.
I figure that's fair enough, don't you?
Yes?
Will?
You want the good news or the bad news?
The bad news.
Let's get the bad news out of the way first.
The bad news is...
not taking us anywhere the shape she's in right now gas tanks empty and the battery's dead okay so what's the good news well she works that's it that's all she needs some gas and a battery okay other than that she's good to go gas is hard to get that stuff yeah Crawford sounds like Crawford is the one place that has everything we need uh-oh maybe we should try there such a terrible idea now hold on a minute surely we have to try if there are people left in this city who are still alive who still have supplies what harm can it do to ask trust me you don't know these people they sound insane you showing up with it's like the worst idea ever i just well put a noose around his neck they don't exactly welcome children with open arms i don't know why we couldn't leave to a different city and get gas but i don't see what other choice we have and just how exactly do you figure we do this this is like the worst idea i've heard that place Sneaking mission!
There might be some way we can sneak in there undetected.
There might actually be a way.
I know the sewer system that runs beneath Crawford like the back of my hand.
Oh?
Y'all wouldn't happen to have a map by any chance.
Wait, we do actually have a map.
Kenny, have you ever heard of using ores?
Sneaking mission!
So we can pass under the perimeter and right into the center.
Solid lead.
We come up right underneath them, take them by surprise, grab what we need, Get out before they even knew what hit them.
That's actually not the worst idea I've ever heard.
I think...
I mean, it's close, but I don't know.
I don't know.
Maybe it could work.
I've thought about it before.
Just never had the people to do it.
But I think...
Vernon, it's not that big of a boat.
Like, everyone is...
Okay.
What do you want in return for all this help?
I think we sacrifice Ben.
Barber doesn't just have what you need for your boat.
They're also well stocked with medical supplies.
Medicine that my people could use, just as yours could.
We can do this.
we have to sacrifice Ben sacrifice decided then we're going to Crawford anyone else have a problem with this plan because we're gonna need every one of us to pull this off yeah man I don't know oh my god I'd rather take a chance on doing something than just sitting around here waiting to die yeah that boat out there is gonna kill us that's gonna get some Ben's gonna get us a little bit farther are you in or out out out we should tonight under cover of dark tonight i'll go let my people know give you all a chance to prepare i'll be back before midnight be careful that's how i'm still alive
i told you to stay in your room how long have you been there you still don't know the guy on the radio is it going to be dangerous it's what going to be dangerous don't play dumb crawford oh it's like we're going back to raven home for real I can't lie to you,
Clem.
Yeah, it's going to be dangerous.
What if her parents are in there?
That'd be crazy.
Make Omi better and get the boat working.
That's why we have to do this.
Do you understand?
I don't want anyone else to die.
I was about to say no one else, no one has died this episode, but we lost Chuck.
Neither do I, Clem.
But sometimes we have to take it.
Trying to sneak around, but the clap of my Georgia Peaches keeps alluring the car.
I should go get ready.
Uh, say what now?
You said you'd need all of us to do this.
She's so cute.
And you said I'm a big help, remember?
Uh-huh.
Molly said Crawford is the only place left in Savannah that still has people.
That means it must be where my mom and dad are, right?
I don't know, it's dangerous.
Where I'm going, it's just too dangerous.
For children, especially.
Yeah, I remember they killed the kids.
You said I'm supposed to always stay close to you.
None of those options were...
Can't I come with you?
None of those options were null.
Take Clem.
Wow, it's a long decision bar.
I don't want her...
I think Omid might die, and then she would be stuck in here with him.
So yeah.
You can come.
But you have to promise to stay quiet and do exactly what you're told the whole time.
I think Omid might die.
If we're not fast enough, you know?
Take her.
So many people are saying take her.
I wasn't influenced by you guys.
I did my own decision.
Yeah, also she's so small.
She might be able to spit through tiny little areas that we might need her like before.
Oh, oh, oh.
Check out what I found in the garage.
She's smart.
She's not like stupid like Duck was.
Might come in handy on this little break-in.
Nice.
Can I talk to you a minute?
What's up?
I took another look at the boat.
She's a 30-footer.
Uh-oh.
So not everyone's gonna think so we're gonna have a capacity problem Yeah, both that size ain't gonna hold more than five people even with one of them a kid me you Clem Krista Oh me Ben Polly assuming everyone makes it back alive.
That's still one too many Even if we cut Molly loose before this is over.
We're gonna have to make a decision.
You're not serious Look, I'm just saying if we want the best chance of Oh, hello Bye, Ben.
Who the hell is this?
This is Bree.
She can help us.
Um.
How?
Help us how.
Yeah, how.
I was a student at the school where Crawford keeps their supplies.
I know the layout.
With her help, we're in and out faster.
Anyone have a problem with that?
Okay.
I guess not.
And what are we waiting for?
Let's get moving.
Okay.
All right.
Chill, Kenny.
I know.
The guy, he knows Bert.
Like, we know.
burning at this point like ready ready whoa freddy are you freddy you're not taking her with us ready freddy not hear anything i said about the kind of place crawford is she can help you take her in there and they find her this little girl's not just excess baggage she's gotten us out of a tight spot more than once yes she has she's coming deal with it you heard the man oh yeah give clem a fake mustache oh wow thank you ben Where did you get that from?
Deal with it.
This should be it.
We're right underneath the center of Crawford.
The old school should be directly above us.
Okay, people.
This is it.
Remember the plan.
We're already here.
This is so scary.
And we stay together.
We find what we need.
I'm scared.
Get the hell out before anyone even knows we're there.
Got it?
If anything happens.
And that part about staying close.
It goes double for you.
sounds like a solid plan can't get a good look above with the cover on oh yeah of course sorry
I'm scared let's go I'm scared ah
where is everybody Honey, there should be guards patrolling.
Not the guards.
Are you disappointed?
It's just strange as well.
Uh-oh, wait, is there a rat?
Over there by the door.
Oh, okay.
I thought someone like ratted them out, you know?
Okay.
Me and Kenny will sneak up, try to take him out quiet.
The rest of you wait for our signal, then follow us over.
Everybody got it?
Okay.
I like that it just saved.
No shooting unless there's no other choice.
Okay.
Oh, why did you, why do you have that?
I'm just gonna run at him.
What the fuck?
Why was it?
Wait, what?
Oh no, no, no.
Wait, why?
Zombie guards?
What the fuck is a walker doing inside here?
Did they all get gone?
Get inside, fast!
Oh my god.
What dummies.
Wait!
So it's been overrun this whole time and everyone's just been afraid of them?
Or are they using the zombies?
I don't think they would though, not to that extent, right?
Fuck!
Do you think they saw us?
Maybe.
Uh, no idea.
Your guess is as good as mine.
Oh, Clem.
Your heads are scared, Clem.
No, I'm sorry.
What the hell happened here?
I thought this place was supposed to be secure.
What always happens, I guess.
Principles of Crawford.
In the end, the dead always win.
Oh, man, we are so screwed.
Shut up, Ben.
Yeah, this is better.
Yeah, he's right.
Vernon's right.
We can deal with walkers easier than armed guards.
Yes, I agree.
I agree.
So long as we don't let him box us in.
We can still do this.
The plan hasn't changed.
The plan hasn't changed?
Every time walkers show up, the plan changes.
Do you even have any idea how many of them are out there?
No.
You want to do a head count?
Or do you want to get what we need and get the hell out of here?
Yeah, shut up, Ben.
Come on.
I think I know which way to head.
Let's just be quiet, okay?
Ben, shut the heck up.
Shut up.
I got a bad feeling about this.
Okay, Shaggy.
Shut up, please.
You want a Scooby snack?
Will that help you?
God!
I can't stand this guy.
That doesn't sound good.
Don't do it.
Wait, why are we opening this?
Why are we...
We ignore it.
Just keep moving.
Yeah, ignore it, ignore it.
I miss Chuck.
Zoixly, I've got a bad feeling about this.
I think it's bad.
Ben's time.
Looks okay.
Everybody in.
Oh, maybe not everybody.
Maybe we check it out first before we decide that everyone should go inside.
You took one little glance and then decided it would be okay?
That everyone should go in?
This place is probably filled with so many, too, because it was a school.
No, Naomi, no Huey, no Ben.
looks like
they were using this room as some kind of command center to be fair ven is just okay so now i know but he's got to grow up if clementine has grown up he can grow up
here here oh just give me a sec the
music is so mysterious fuel where can we find some fuel for the boat there's a maintenance shed across from the playground here if they were stored fuel that's probably where it'll be okay and the medicine where would be the best place to look for medicine right here nurses station they were using it as a medical facility okay how do you know that oh just makes sense doesn't it so then we just need a battery molly this auto shop it's right next door yep it's called Herman's you can't miss it okay I'll make the run to the maintenance shed it'll be faster if I go with you I can take you right to it I'll come to no two people's enough you stay here see if you can use any of those tools we brought to get that armor door open they might need to shoot our way out of here yeah i'll go for the medicine i'll come with you i know what to take okay okay guess that leaves me to go find us a battery i'll go with you watch your back can we trust molly everyone be careful stay close to one another
wait why did we give him a weapon that's ours oh i guess molly's got like the the climber pick so
can we trust molly but if crawford has fallen what about me what can i do you come with girl i need you to stay here with ben and watch over our command center i'm putting you in charge of it okay no wait what this is a terrible idea lee what you're leaving me with ben yeah that's what i'm saying ben i'm leaving him with you understand oh okay back before you know it No!
Wait, this is so bad!
Lee, Lee, use your brain!
Lee!
Use your brain for two seconds!
Hopscotch.
He's doing hopscotch and squats.
Clem is smart.
She is, but she's small!
Creepy.
Those are kind of creepy.
Wait, where did we see it?
We saw one in that house.
Might come back for these later.
Any reading material would be nice once we get on that boat.
I think these are elementary level.
Ben.
You need any help with that?
Thanks.
I got it.
Just once, I'd like to do something useful, you know?
Yes, please.
Yeah, that'd make a nice change.
That'd make a nice change of pace.
Wow, no need to agree with me quite so much.
Thanks for the vote of confidence.
Well, I'll let you get on with it.
I hope you remember that, Ben.
No, wait.
there is something you can help me with something that's been on my mind I could use your opinion okay what is it it's Kenny since I've been helping him work on the boat I've gotten to know him a little better okay good guy you know and it's eating me up knowing what I know I've been thinking about telling him the truth come on this again it's my fault duck and Kacha got killed if I hadn't screwed up back at the motor inn they'd still be alive how am I supposed to just carry something like that around I have to tell him.
I don't have time for this.
I really don't have time for this.
You don't get it, Lee.
What am I supposed to do whenever he talks about Kacha and Duck?
Just nod and pretend like it wasn't my fault.
I can't do it anymore.
At least he takes the responsibility.
There'll come a time when he's ready to hear it, but it's not now.
It's not now.
Not yet.
I hear you.
I'm going to get back to this.
Oh.
quite a system here Crawford's final solution wait what did it say oh initials of oh number of ineligible citizens found number of citizens brought to Crawford number of walkers found I was close initials a person conducting the search days since outbreak oh I didn't notice it said OB ah I was so close I appreciate Ben solving the boat problem himself
I was so close!
Ineligible citizens.
That's kind of messed up, though.
So I did get the initials of the person, right?
Didn't get the code right.
Like the, or the numbers, right?
Or, like, the 7-1-0-O-B.
But then number of walkers.
Number of citizens brought.
Ah!
How do I get out of this?
Oh!
My bed.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Look, it's like she's in school.
You okay, Clem?
This desk is just like the ones we have in my school.
I know it's weird, but I kind of miss it.
Being in school.
Nah.
I miss teaching.
Me too.
I used to be a teacher, remember?
You got the real-life version correct to be fair?
Set up a little classroom.
Well, in the real-life one, there's only two numbers.
Will there be homework?
No homework.
do you think things will ever be normal again just like the way they were before remember what cat said what she said i don't know sweet pea what she said but we all have to believe they will remember what cat just said back on the farm speed up she said we'll all be home soon and now she's dead but we're not we're still alive and we have to keep her alive too
dang oh there's more paste eat it just a bunch of paste more like a bunch of snacks what's going on in the rest of the world i i actually don't know what's going on like i don't remember i don't think i ever got far enough in the walking done to know what happens in the rest of the world
Nothing but crayons and construction paper.
Isn't there like a spin-off series of...
Uh, what's his name?
So according to...
Norman Reedus?
He was at the maintenance shed.
Medicine might be at the nurse's office.
He's pretty much a therapist at this point.
The battery would probably be at the auto shop out through here.
Okay.
Where do I go?
Fire escape, nurse's office, door to the plate.
We are where?
I guess it's fine.
Daryl, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, there was like a...
He was like, he like goes to France or something, no?
Hey, where'd Molly go?
Principles of Crawford.
All illnesses and medical conditions must be disclosed to the...
Council.
Children under 14, not admitted without authorization.
Anyone asked to leave Crawford cannot return under any circumstances.
Theft or looting within the district will not be tolerated.
Waste not.
Make the most of your rations.
Minto eating dog treats and paste.
I'm starting to understand why you're a ghost.
Oh, the leader.
Must be the guy who ran this place.
Looks like he figured himself as some kind of supreme leader.
I thought it was a wanted sign.
Oh, there she is.
The alleyway to the auto shops down here.
You coming or not?
Holy moly.
Okay, ma'am, please.
Shell casings.
Wait, what am I climbing?
I've already been fired.
They're worthless.
Okay, we saw these earlier.
She went this way, right?
Exit to the alley.
Okay, I think this is her.
So loud.
I know, Molly, please.
Yell louder.
This must be the door to the alleyway.
It's not going to go off, right?
Like, the long way.
Where the hell is Molly?
Yeah, where did Molly go?
Why did she leave us?
Molly, you out here?
She has a weapon.
Guess I'm not going that way.
Molly!
Looters will be shot on sight.
I thought I heard something.
I do hear something.
Oh, gosh.
Molly.
I'm scared.
Wait.
Hold on.
Trying to look at this.
Looters will be shot.
I said, okay.
Anything in here?
A TV.
We're very slowly making our way out.
idea required?
Beyond this point?
Who has a photo idea on them?
Well, climbing the fence isn't an option.
Look up at the shed?
It won't let me.
Actually, I'm kind of...
Oh, inside.
Oh, okay.
Ah, thank you.
Are these stable?
I guess...
Wait.
but it's like this is like definitely a one-way street like once we go that way how do we get back okay no looters looters however are welcome where is molly is it gonna be so loud i'm scared uh damn it's jam tight okay
molly molly oh no oh better not get too close
okay uh
What the?
Why is it looking?
Leave him!
Don't yell.
He's mine.
Wait, what?
He looks like a...
What?
Where have you been?
Where the hell have you been?
She's got a vendetta against somebody.
He looks like a vampire.
Molly?
Molly!
What?
Uh, I think you got it.
I think you got it.
one more
he's wearing medical scrubs some kind of scientist or doctor maybe yeah well he ain't shit new yeah
did you find us a way in yeah but the garage door is jammed can't raise it
not a problem so she's just been been like oh yeah that'll work running around like spider-man oh I wonder if it's because someone was shouting oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh come on they'll get stuck on the barbed wire surely
No, he's gonna crawl in.
He's twitching out there.
Take a look around.
I'll make sure no stragglers get under this door.
Okay.
And if there's somebody in here?
Looks like it's the hose for the lift hydraulics.
Okay, lift panel.
Oh, there's probably the battery in there.
Okay, we're probably going to have to lower the car, right?
More of Crawford's rules.
How did anybody get like this?
Some kind of walk in there.
Can I open this?
Wow, they got a big truck.
Does this work?
What?
Well, I can see where the battery is.
should be just kidding it's not perfect i was looking at the wrong thing i know cars had their own semi trucks i know cars molly who was that molly let's talk real quick something you need um not that walker what was all that about back there he came at me up on that rooftop tried to take a bite out of me so i took care of business what you got a problem with me killing
town on him a little more than you needed to hey you never really know when those things are all the way dead I was just making sure I don't think you got this battery or not time's wasting so Crawford what do you think happened to Crawford no no don't care as far as I'm concerned these fuckers got what was coming to them I wonder what if she like started it you know all the people who died here huh I have about as much for them as they did for the sick and the old and anyone else they didn't think was fit to belong in their little paradise.
So yeah, fuck them.
You know what?
I felt that.
Think I can borrow that hook thing of yours?
I don't know.
Hilda and I have been through a lot together.
They were like killing other people.
That's what I call her.
Don't judge.
Hilda.
Please, can I borrow Hilda?
I'll take good care of her.
She won't get a scratch.
Thank you for Hilda.
I got your promise now.
Not a scratch.
It sounds like a death flag for Hilda.
Uh-oh.
That blinking must be an anti-theft system.
Wait, which means...
The chance of a working battery being in that car.
Yeah, but it might sound an alarm.
How...
What's the word?
Left for dead.
I can't reach it up there.
Okay, let's do the hydraulic.
Oh, wait.
Let's look at the pan.
Wait, can I...
Do the panel that controls the hydraulic lift over there.
Alarm without battery.
No, it has a battery.
That's what we're saying.
No power.
Okay.
Then we gotta cut it.
We gotta cut the hose.
It's a little leak.
Just a small, small leak.
There we go.
I did it.
Uh-oh.
Why is the music bad?
Whoa, whoa.
That's probably not good.
No, shit.
Oh, oh, grab the battery.
Finally something goes right.
This is right.
This is right to you.
Oh my god.
Take it, take it, take it, take it.
Please.
Got that one off.
Okay, got that one off.
It's off.
Oh, we got a lot of time.
Ish.
Got it.
Wow, but we still got a problem here.
Put it in here.
I'll carry it.
Okay, now we know for sure the battery works.
Yeah?
Move your ass!
I'm moving my ass!
She's telling me to twerk.
Okay, why?
Why did we go here?
Skylight.
Okay.
It's shut!
Shoot it out!
Okay!
Is she gonna be able to get us?
Okay.
Oh my gosh, so much better than Kenny.
Okay, so now we're on a roof.
Yeah.
Do you ever stop complaining?
I know, right?
Wait a second.
This is so much better than being down there, I'd say.
Wait, how are we supposed to make that?
Come on, what are you, chicken?
Jump.
chicken what did you call me well now that you mention it I got her oh yeah baby yeah baby back to the future yeah that's exactly what I was thinking I thought back to the future reference what did you call me chicken come on later something I gotta do first what catch you later Molly wait you've still got the battery your beat yeah yeah I think I'll hold on to it make sure you don't leave without me see you back in class Molly or she's gonna leave the hell is she doing and take the boat herself bloody lockers Logan is that I don't know the combination did he minty McFly can't open it without the
Oh gosh, I thought those were Zombo's.
You guys need any help?
Thanks, but I think we're almost in.
We're taking care of it, Lee.
Don't worry.
Telltale made a Back to the Future game.
They did!
No way!
That's fun.
What else we got going on in here?
This is to the out.
This is where we went.
Okay, this is where we, sorry.
I forgot.
A little lost.
Okay, let's go back to the classroom and check on Clem.
Little help.
Little help here.
What's happening?
Oh my god.
Kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill.
E!
Fuck.
The doors won't close on the bike.
I wonder why.
I need something.
There we go.
Break the door with something.
Something.
Grab the hatchet.
okay but the glass
how what did you do how did this happen let's not start high-fiving each other just yet oh my god it's cracking it's cracking it's literally cracking okay no urgency at all okay
oh nice yeah and we made out pretty good too great work kenny oh how you doing with that door not so good i don't think he knows how to lock that let me give you a hand did you get that battery yet oh yes yeah molly has it she should be back here soon she'd better be she better not leave us
Thanks for all your help back there.
You're welcome.
I don't think we would have made it without you.
No problem.
We're all on the same team.
So we're just going to go into her trauma.
So you're a cancer survivor.
Like Vernon and the others.
Yeah.
I was diagnosed when I was in college.
Been getting treatment ever since.
Just when I was starting to get better, when I thought there might be some hope, all this happened.
Oh, no.
Lost my whole family.
No.
I'm the only one.
He's the one who survived.
Funny how things work out at home.
Wait, so she is not completely better?
That's so sad.
How long have you known Vernon?
A couple of years.
He ran our support group.
He was really great helping me come to terms with my disease.
But how do you come to terms with something like this?
With a place like Crawford.
I don't know what I or the other survivors would have done without Vernon.
Oh.
He's the one who held us together.
Oh, no.
Vernon's going to die.
a death flag for Vernon oh no Vernon's not gonna make it what do you think about this whole I'd rather not talk about it too many awful memories even being back here gives me a bad feeling even now with everyone dead I got no sympathy for what happened to these people they weeded out the sick and the old even children those least able to defend themselves so that they could save their own skins whatever happened here however Crawford fell I consider it poetic justice Damn,
girl, that's cool.
It's how I feel.
If you'd seen what I've seen, you'd feel the same.
We know that they killed children and old people and everything.
Maybe you should go get that battery or help with the medicine.
We know that they were killing people.
Clem!
You okay, Clem?
Yeah.
Where's Molly?
I don't know.
I hope she's okay yeah i hope so too she'll be fine she's pretty tough yeah she's cool i like molly just sit tight okay i hope she lives go take care of a few things all right so there's like a joke on tick tock that i think is kind of funny it's like if somebody like watches a video and they like like the video or like the person they'll be like you're so funny i hope you don't go bald
I almost said it and being like I hope she doesn't die I almost said I hope she doesn't go bald I don't know why it started I just think it's kind of what do we still need we already got the fuel in the but if you are bald bald is beautiful good to go so where's this battery you found Molly has it I said so three times well she'd better bring it back here I don't know why you She saved your life,
didn't she?
Yeah, but what has she done for me lately?
What have you done?
Huh?
Wait, oh, did I just...
Is it the same combo?
How are you guys doing with that door?
Okay, it's the same thing.
Slower than I'd like.
Don't worry, we'll get it open.
I think it depends on how short you cut her hair.
She'll go bald.
Minto, you're so funny, I hope you don't go bald.
That would, like, never happen.
It's literally impossible.
I would never go bald.
Can I
leave?
This way.
Okay, Molly, it's time to come back now.
Molly, it's time to come home.
I forgot about them.
I can just leave?
Oh my gosh.
We're just gonna walk past there.
Molly?
Shit.
Kristen Vernon must be trapped in there.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Um.
Do I shoot?
They're all gonna come at me.
Where did they come from?
I don't know.
Look up?
What do you mean?
Look up!
There's nothing up!
What do you mean up?
Down.
Look down?
There's nothing up.
The speaker?
You think we can get it?
But it's not like lit up.
I'll try.
It won't let me shoot it.
I have to shoot one of them.
I'll take down this big guy.
Oh, okay.
I was like, oh, they didn't notice at all.
Oh, my God.
Oh, kind of fast.
You guys okay in here?
This is me?
What the hell happened?
Yeah.
after we got inside i think they must have heard us rooting around in here the whole place is infested they're everywhere calm down we're trying to leave what about your bald head like a crystal ball oh it's bald take a look looks like they were keeping all the prescription meds in that safe locked up tight uh can we bust it open we can bust it open maybe with enough time I don't know how much of that we have.
It'd be a hell of a lot quicker if we just knew the four-digit combination.
Well, I doubt they just wrote it down and left it here for us to find.
We should just try busting it open.
The streamer excels at all.
Okay, you get started.
I'll take a look around, see if I can find anything useful.
Like a combination.
I'll have to take time to rest later, I think.
But I'm sleepy now.
Just a bunch of papers.
No safe combination, though.
I know it.
Eight zero zero eight.
Looks like some kind of medical file.
I know it.
Eight zero zero eight.
Oh, wait.
We can watch them.
Oh, dang.
I was going to say we can watch them unlock it.
Wait.
Why is there a camcorder at the bed?
What's this on the floor?
The baby?
It's a sonogram.
Is that for a baby?
Just dried blood on this printout.
Headed on the floor.
Looks like a trail of it.
Oh, I'm scared.
I saved to the camera over there.
Then out the door.
What the hell happened here?
Is that for the baby?
Is that for a baby?
Does the sonogram show you the baby?
Y'all already checked these drawers?
Yes, Lee.
Nothing in there worth taking.
Okay, you don't need to be so patronizing.
organizing there's a first aid kit right here already cleaned out just kidding too short it must be eight zero zero eight one three five yeah yeah yeah what what were they recording i'm not gonna shoot it i think that's dangerous hey krista yeah about clementine i hope i did the right thing bring a clementine with us.
I think she's fine.
This place isn't exactly safe.
Then why did you?
Because leaving her alone with Omeid didn't seem any safer.
What's that supposed to mean?
No offense, Krista, but Omeid's pretty sick.
If he dies with Clementine alone in the house with him, that is not going to happen.
Do you hear me?
That is not going to happen.
We're going to get these meds to Omeid, and he's going to be fine.
He's going to be fine.
You're right.
I'm sorry.
Are you feeling okay?
Why do we a timer why are you asking me that it's just that you've been looking a little pale the past couple of days you've been throwing up come on you just dug up a rotting dog car she's a baby she's has the baby lee i'm fine she has baby okay worry about oh mead we've got to get him these meds are you making any progress with the safe she has baby without the combination i don't know how we're going to get this damn thing open if we don't get back to omid with okay we'll figure it out oh my god look lee i just want to get back to omid let me do my thing all right okay okay me and lee say the same thing sometimes wait open the camcorder yeah no tape inside okay just kidding i think we tried that before okay we can talk to vernon oh wait uh how's it coming slow too slow i'm worried by the time we managed to get this thing open it may be too late about molly molly helped me get the battery we needed that's great one down where is she i don't know she took off had some kind of errand
she needed to run took off who has errands in the apocalypse yeah don't worry get free i hope so that girl doesn't really strike me as a team player more than mercenary kind
you want my medical opinion as soon as we'd get him some strong antibiotics to start fighting that infection the better let's just leave it at that huh yeah thank you for coming with us I just wanted to thank you for coming she went to get milk for all your help I really appreciate it from that farm we were at it's times like these we've got to help each other the most right and we're no better than those Crawford's sons of bitches yeah I heard that I'll go see if I can find something that'll help us get that safe open.
Good idea.
Where can I find a copier?
Oh, maybe the copier has something.
What is this?
A copy machine.
Not that it matters with no power around here.
But it might have something in it.
Okay.
We don't check.
We don't check those things.
Uh, I think I looked at everything.
Looks pretty sturdy.
No way we're gonna force that open.
We might be able to find something 8-0-0-8.
Omi needs that medicine.
We have to get it open now.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna go check out Zot.
I'm gonna go work.
It might not be in here.
Because also there was like the combination to the locker, right?
So...
Copy machine their butts probably.
Okay, we're looking for a safe combination.
Oh, the zombie...
Well, they are still here.
Oh, I thought the zombie bodies disappeared.
Anything in the vending machine.
Can we look at the bloody locker again?
Uh...
Any other lockers?
Wait, maybe this has something.
Must be the guy who ran this place.
Uh...
Looks like he figured himself...
There's a file on the desk.
Yeah, but it...
I clicked on it.
No, I don't think that has anything.
Check the file.
Oh, did I miss it?
I don't know.
I didn't actually see if it gave me a second option.
I'll go check again.
I think...
Oh, oh, I can pick it up.
Oh!
Anna Correa.
Guess she must have been a patient here.
And what's this?
Are they making...
Sorry.
Zombie babies.
No taping, sir.
No, I have a tape now.
I have a tape.
Oh, there it is.
Tape, tape, tape.
Vernon, Krista, come look at this.
They're doing experiments.
This is day 82 since the outbreak.
Dr. Logan in consultation with patient Anna Correa.
How do they keep this charged?
Oh, I guess I did have, like, batteries and fuel and stuff.
Regulations.
Oberson has ordered me to keep records of all medical examinations and consultations.
Is that the guy she killed?
You brace yourself, Anna.
The sonogram confirms that you're pregnant.
Oh, God, oh, God, oh, God.
As you know, the rules are very clear.
The termination is mandatory.
You don't have to tell them.
just nausea but you gave me something for it and it went away this is my problem not yours if oberson finds out that i concealed evidence of a pregnancy i'm sorry but these are the rules i'm going to give you a sedative it'll make the procedure easier on you i don't want the procedure i want my baby is this like molly's sister or something and they killed her you don't have a choice now if you like you can take some time with this but i need you to come back no later I have no choice but to inform overs on myself.
I'm trying to get the baby out.
Killed her or something.
Oh, she left.
Damn it.
We almost had it.
What the hell kind of place was this?
Like Molly said, the worst kind.
Lee, maybe there's another tape.
We gotta keep looking.
I think I recognize that doctor.
He was one of the walkers out in the alley by the auto shop.
Yeah.
Maybe you should search it.
See what he's got on it.
But that alleyway is like compromised now, no?
wait it says right there 82 oh i guess that was like the oh it said 82 ob so 82 days after the outbreak they did say that too oh my gosh wait but that that area is compromised no
bleh bleh bleh bleh won't you blood i hear more guys i hear more guys Surely, if Molly were around, she'd be able to help us.
Dana, thank you!
Yeah, the Nosferatu looking guy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have to go back up again?
Oh?
Oh yeah, there we go.
Ah!
Oh my gosh!
Kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill!
Where did you come from?
Oh, the TV saved me!
Oh, that scared me so bad.
Wait, he's gone?
Oh, no, he's there.
How do we get back?
I'm going to stomp him.
Good thing their heads are so squishy.
You know?
This is definitely the guy.
Ah, Nosferato.
Like we can just stomp them so easily like a like a tomato.
This might be just what we need.
What's this?
Oh, we got the code to Logan's locker.
Uh-oh.
Time to go.
Lee!
Stop.
Get your own lines, Lee.
Come on.
all right let's use let's open the bloody locker
so embarrassing one of us has to change oh safe combination is gotta be on one of these okay nice all right well maybe now i think one of them will show molly
i found two more tapes one of them is dated October 10th that's the day after the first one we watched put it in saving why did the game save have you made a decision I thought you said I didn't have a choice well technically you do you can terminate the pregnancy or leave Crawford of course that would be a death sentence for both you have your own child.
Maybe that's best.
I stayed up all last night thinking about this.
Why are we even trying to survive, to keep on living, if this is what it takes, if this is what it's turned us into?
I don't make the rules, Anna.
Doctor, I'm begging you, please help me.
Maybe one day, when things are different, you can try again.
But for now, today, we have to do this.
Oh.
Zoom?
Enhance?
is he the cause of it all that would be awesome is he the cause she's the reason crawford went to oh
still had time to turn off the camera though i think we know what happened to crawford more importantly we got the combination
Looks like the sick system these bastards cooked up to protect themselves wound up destroying them.
Yeah.
Can't say I'll shed too many tears over it.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Oh, I should look at this like that.
Antibiotics, morphine, we'll take as much of this as we can carry.
Yahoo!
Okay, I think we're good.
This is more than enough for your people and mine.
Let's go.
Yay!
You know, I found a third tape in the locker outside.
Oh, yeah.
else on there we got the meds from me that's all i care about we'll head back to the classroom don't take too long lee it's gonna show molly it's gonna show molly no one else will know but me about molly i'm gonna know about molly i'm gonna know what is it this was 76 days right so It was like a week or...
It was time!
As fun as this was, I have to put a stop to this little arrangement.
This is the last I can give you.
Oberson had someone down here yesterday taking inventory.
He's really cracking down.
I just can't risk it.
We had a deal.
Yes, we had a deal.
We don't anymore.
My sister needs this medicine.
Without it, she'll die or she'll start showing symptoms and they'll take her away.
can't let that happen i'm sorry molly i've done all i can but i have to look out for myself here yeah that's the crawford way isn't it why do you do that right in front of the camera right well well well well well
Let's head back, I suppose.
It'll help the door.
Wait, I don't hear them banging on the door anymore.
Oh, my gosh, you scared me.
Where the fuck have you been?
Sightseeing.
I'll take that battery now.
Oh, yeah.
About that.
Molly?
Molly.
I'm sorry.
I'm just kidding.
Oh, okay.
Here you go.
She's just Josh.
Dang, that thing is huge.
You were carrying that in your backpack this whole time.
Where did I put it?
In my back pocket?
What's that?
Nothing.
Got a picture of her sister.
I know you're from Crawford.
You can quit with the act, Molly.
What?
Who told you that?
I saw you on a security tape.
Why'd you lie to me?
I said there were stories about Crawford.
I never said that's how I knew about it.
I never lied to you.
Lied by omission.
I don't owe you anything.
You saved my life twice, but you can't tell me the truth.
Yeah.
Are we really gonna do this now?
You know what?
I guess that's up to you.
I used to live here with my sister.
She was 14 years old.
14?
When the dead started walking and Crawford shut itself in, it seemed like a pretty good deal.
She didn't look 14.
We were safe.
We had everything we needed to survive.
Then the rules started coming down.
No one who couldn't justify their place or in their keep.
No one who required special care.
I thought she was like...
This is so bad.
I thought she was like their 30s.
Oh, is it different, girl?
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Kept her safe for as long as I could.
But in the end, I couldn't protect her.
That's when I got out.
Crawford, they always talked about how their system worked.
How anything was better than becoming one of them.
but i saw what they'd already become i just wish i could have seen different person okay okay before they came and took my sister away oh this is all i have left of her oh i didn't have time to take it before i got out of crawford i just wanted it okay it's okay money i understand she's pretty what the hell oh no i think that's our cue to get the hell out of here I think so.
I don't care.
We could, I kind of want to play where, uh-oh.
Where Lee is just an asshole.
Where he's bully Maguire and he says, I miss the part where that's my problem.
Every time.
What?
Ben!
Sorry, sorry.
I just got spooked by those bells.
Where's Clementine?
And then I heard someone coming.
Did you leave Clementine alone?
No, Kenny's with her.
Okay, good.
We still can't open that armory door.
He sent me out to look for something we can use to bust it open.
I found this.
That was for the door.
Where did you get that?
Oh my god.
I just found it.
It was stuck in the door handle at the end of the hallway back there.
Shit!
Lee!
Shoot this fucker!
Oh my god.
Wait, who got her?
Thanks.
I did not do that.
It wasn't me.
I'm going, kid.
This is fine.
Thanks.
Clementine
What the fuck is going on they're coming oh shit that ought to hold them sir But now how do we get out?
I'm speechless.
We could just get this damn door open.
I'm speechless Come on damn you.
I am speechless Oh my god if you see this is my fault all my fault.
What the hell's he babbling about Ben?
We talked about this.
No Wait, I want to know what he meant.
What do you mean?
This is all you're calling.
Penny, I'm so sorry.
Oh!
I'm so sorry, Nan.
Kid, you saved the best time.
Whatever you did, save it for later.
Then, shut the fuck up.
Yes.
Fuck you, Lee.
I can't do this anymore.
It's been me all along, putting all of us in danger.
Kacha and Duck, it was all me.
It was all me.
This is not the time.
Wait a minute.
What are you saying?
Oh, God.
It was me who made the deal with the bandits at the motor inn.
Slipping them supplies.
I thought maybe I could keep them off our backs.
When it got discovered, that's when they attacked and that's when duck
Let him at him let him at kick his ass later I agree with you.
You should kick his ass, but now's not the time Focus on getting out of here.
You little piss ant you're fucking dead.
You hear me dad my wife and child
You can warp his skinny little ass later.
Right now.
We gotta go.
Oh my god Nice group you got here Not the time Molly if this asshole thinks he's getting on my boat after what he did He's out of his motherfucking mind.
We'll sort it out later You can stay behind.
We just gotta go.
Kenny will sort this out later after we get out of here Okay, nothing to sort out.
I just told you the way it's gonna be.
I should have just said nothing to get left behind yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I know you mean well but all I want to do is get back to oh me you put that at risk wait don't I get a vote oh no of course you do and it's nice he's my friend we don't leave friends behind that's my vote oh girl on second thought I think I think I'm gonna abstain.
Lee?
Oh, we cut him loose.
I'm sorry, Ben.
I've got to do what's best for the group.
And that means cutting you loose.
Sorry.
Sorry, Clem.
What about the rest of us?
Don't we get a say?
We don't know you!
You don't know him!
Now can we go?
Damn right.
Vernon, come on.
Don't we get a vote?
Who are you?
So much for the armory.
Oh, my God.
What's left of it?
A few rounds.
That's it.
Why is Ben still here?
You didn't close that door behind us?
I couldn't.
The lock was busted.
Great.
Just fucking great.
Come on.
There's got to be a way out.
down here oh
my god shut the door please shut the door it's not gonna hold back upstairs sorry you don't get to stay oh my god wait wait look okay nice we'll take that oh my god oh my god it only takes out use s okay i'm backing up I'm backing up, I'm backing up.
I'm backing up.
I'm back and I'm shooting and I'm backing up and I'm shooting.
Ah, oh my god, she's still crawling on the ground.
Unlimited ammo?
Let's go?
Yeah, yeah, oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Uh, no one's coming.
Oh, they're coming.
Come on, look down!
Try and get your leg!
Oh my god.
Can I get you an egg?
Come on.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's good.
Oh, yeah.
Where'd they come from?
Who's?
Oh.
Okay, let's go.
Now we're hatch...
We're chop-chopping.
Chop chopping!
Yeah, yeah, chop chopping!
We're chop chopping!
Yeah, baby!
Ooh, how is he so...
Oh, no, I hatchet.
No!
Here, Clem.
It's all right, Clem.
I'm fine.
Any way out of here?
Push Ben down the stairs.
way down you didn't come into town from the railroad did you yeah we did why oh never mind i can see the sewer oh no the horde oh no what are we waiting for go go oh my god oh my god no they're still following yeah come on let's go
ben don't be stupid oh my god
there's no time you have to go now fucking around ben come on let go damn it get clam and the others out of here
He's like, what are you doing with it?
What are you doing?
What are you doing with that guy?
Well, Ben.
We both know.
Let me go.
Oh my god.
Pull him up!
You little...
I can't!
I can't win a- Coward!
Ah!
Everything okay?
Oh no.
Oh Mead is oh dead.
Oh Mead?
Are you breathing?
Oh.
Uh, is he dead?
Hold on.
is he dead Trista thought's almost stay back I never should have left you I'm so sorry Krista get away from him what would you have done oh hey back already he's so cute we got you medicine he's so smiley I feel like I could use some oh my god oh me You okay,
kid?
You look worse than I do.
We almost didn't make it out of there because of this asshole.
Yeah.
Should have left him behind when we had the chance.
Sorry, Keani.
Guys, what the hell happened out there?
Thank you guys for the super chat.
Let someone else tell you.
I got work to do.
Okay, with a little luck, you should start feeling better pretty soon.
Oh, Mia's just taking a nap up in here.
I'll stay here for a few more hours to check on him.
Let me know if you need it.
He's so whimsical, yeah.
Thanks, Doc.
Yes.
Thank you so much.
I need some water soon Maybe now's a good time for you and me To have a little talk In private Okay What are we talking about?
Hello?
I'm sorry about Bree Listen, man About what happened to Bree Her name makes me hungry for cheese What do you mean by that?
You don't think by now I got you figured?
You don't strike me as someone Who has a lot of consideration for others What?
You did to get me to come here with you in the first place.
You expect me to believe you give a shit that it wound up costing Brie her life?
Now just hold on a damn minute.
Listen.
No, you listen.
You got some good people here and they look to you as their leader.
Well, I'm here to tell you the kind of leader you are.
They're not going to make it much better.
And you're kidding yourself if you think putting them all on a boat is going to solve anything.
Wait, why is he saying all this all of a sudden?
But I know you care about that little girl.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
Does he want...
What kind of an offer?
Is he wanting to take Clem?
I'll take her off your hands.
No.
Take her back with me, to my people.
We're well supplied, well hidden, and a lot of us have had kids of our own.
Do you remember the lie?
And now Crawford's fallen, we got nothing left to fear.
About her being my daughter?
She'll be safe with us.
Safer than she will be if she stays with you.
I promise you.
That's what you want for her, isn't it?
safe i'm gonna pretend you didn't say any of this and give you a chance to walk away but you are you told burning off i know you think you're doing what's best for her and if you were her real father we wouldn't be having this conversation but you're not are you just another one of your lives that little girl's in my care we've been through more together than you can imagine anyone who tries to get between me and her anyone it's gonna wind up dead do you hear me take your hands off me
Vernon in another timeline you shot me I haven't forgiven that Minto remembers this
hello hey going somewhere are you leaving yeah I'm about to head out lecture from a guy who's master plan is to hide behind a sign and a zombie infested that's what i was fun i was about to say wait you should come with us wait you should come with us talking about kenny's working on the boat right now thought you were coming with us god knows you earned it yeah i've been thinking it over it's not for me sounds like it'd be pretty crowded and i never did like the water molly you sure about this i'm sure i've always done better on my own anyhow I mean,
she's just got herself.
She's...
Tell the others for me.
She's handled herself real well.
You take care of yourself, Molly.
You too, Lee.
But yeah, they're gonna run out of food in that sewer eventually.
And...
And you be sure to take care of that little girl.
You know she thinks the world of you.
Like, they have no other plan.
They would just...
Good luck.
Ain't nothing to do with luck.
Bye, Gwen.
Bye, Molly!
She was so good.
Can I have your climbing pick?
Hey, sweet pea.
Kenny's working on the boat.
I know.
What are we going to do after he fixes it?
Where will we go?
Someplace else.
Someplace better.
Clem, honey.
Oh, her parents.
He's been going to be okay.
Oh, he doesn't seem the same since he got back.
It's his own fault.
He's just feeling down right now.
Truth is, he brought this on himself.
What do you mean?
Look, Ben's a good kid.
He means well.
He keeps trying to help.
But every time he does, he winds up putting the rest of us in even more of a jam.
What happened to Kaja and Duck?
He feels like he was responsible for that.
And the fact is...
He's right.
He was.
But he still saved him.
Yeah, I still saved him.
Before we leave tomorrow, will we have time to look for my parents?
Yes, Lot.
I'd like to, Clem, but I don't think we'll have time.
We really shouldn't stay here any longer.
It's not safe.
Wait, who was the person on the radio?
Oh.
We?
We are gonna reach out, right?
Oh.
No.
Why didn't you?
Come on.
You want to be a father to her.
Be a father.
Why is he just sitting there like that?
Clementine?
Oh, no.
No.
Clementine?
Oh, no.
Oh no.
Hello?
Oh!
Chapter 7, Episode 4.
Clementine?
Is she actually gone now?
Not the hat.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Go get her hat.
Oh.
The guy on the radio.
Clem?
Silent Hill.
It's hers!
Oh my god!
Oh gosh, this game.
Oh no, it has blood on it, no!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh fuck.
No.
Lee?
You out here?
Lee are you crazy what are you doing out here it ain't safe Lee where's Clementine she's not in her room Vernon ain't in the house either what the hell is going on I gotta show up oh
my god cut off the arm way no no no fucking way there's no time to worry about me Clementine's gone there's no chance she just wandered off on her own cut off he are and who the hell took her i don't know last night vernon came to me and offered to take her with him said she'd be better off son of a i knew we couldn't trust that fucker wherever she is i have to find her okay what do you need from us uh i need to have to find me not have much time we have a better chance of finding her if we all go together what do you We're all responsible for Clementine.
And in your condition, you may not make it to her in time.
No.
She needs our help.
All of our help.
Damn right.
Wow, they accepted it so easily.
Wow.
So that's settled then.
We'll look for Clementine together.
Hell yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
I appreciate it.
Kenny.
You've always been there for me, Lee.
Always had my back when it mattered.
What kind of friend would I be if I wasn't there for you now?
Mitten or not, I'm with you to the end.
You can count on me.
What about you, Ben?
Now hold on a minute.
You're not really thinking about bringing him with us, are you?
I need Kenny.
Wait.
Ben, I'm sorry, but I need Kenny on this.
Maybe you should stay with the boat.
He chose that to work.
Okay, sure.
Just don't fucking lay a finger on it.
You here?
Okay, guys.
We should go find Vernon.
See if he took her.
Extra meat shield.
Maybe I should have brought him.
Are we okay just leaving the boat like this?
With only Ben to look after it?
What choice do we have?
If anything has happened to that boat when I get back, I will fucking bury you in that backyard.
Are we clear?
It was.
He's like, mm-hmm.
Only Ben.
Nobody trusts Ben.
Oh, me and Krista just met Ben, and they already don't trust him.
Oh, wait, are they gone?
No way.
No way did they leave?
There's no food in there.
They left!
Everything's gone!
Where the hell are they?
Oh my god.
Looks like they got out of here in a hurry.
Vernon, get out here!
There doesn't have to be any trouble here.
All I want is the girl.
Give her back and nobody needs to get hurt.
They just dipped?
Now is the time for me.
Is that what that says?
What?
Oh my god, he saw the horde.
Did not tell them.
And then they all left.
Wow!
Wow, he saw it.
Clementine, are you all right?
Where are you?
Vernon, you son of a bitch.
Hello, Lee.
Who is this?
It's not Vernon if that's what you're thinking.
And you should really watch your tone.
I choose my next word.
It's Ben.
What do you want for a minute?
What?
Virgil?
Episode 5, no time left!
Wow, I was majority for...
For a lot of this.
You and 74% of players killed the boy in the attic.
You and 33% of players threatened or lied to Vernon.
You and 73% of players brought Clementine.
You and 66% of players pulled...
Well, O'Mean did not die, so honestly, we could have left her.
You and 66% of players pulled up Ben.
Most people did!
Wow.
Platypus, the next word is platypus.
You and 80% of players showed the bite.
Wow.
No, Elle, thank you so much for the 20 gives.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm wow wow wow cowards
20% dokees for what I think I saw someone mention that she would she said that she would show the or she would hide a bite in the zombie apocalypse she's out here destroying communities
goodness bite hiders All my friends don't all my friends like me with my bite.
They're all still with me.
They joined me
All my friends are still here they don't mind my bite in fact they might like it a little bit They're like kind of sexy with that bite mark girl nice work me though thank you
You're like what kind of Where'd you get that bite mark girl?
The bite adds flavors better than a tattoo.
Have you heard about that?
How sometimes, like, I've seen this before.
Where, like, people will have, like, their partner, whatever, bite them, and then they'll get that tattooed on them.
Do you guys want me to upload my bite mark so that you can get it?
Okay, you can get it tattooed on your body.
Members content.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's members.
All my friends were there for me.
And Ben was also there too.
Yeah.
I'll upload a bite mark and then you can go get it tattooed wherever you want on your body.
You can have it on your leg like I was a crawling zombie.
and i bit your leg and then you can show it off to people and be like i'm bit i'm bit i'm not gonna make it i'm not gonna make it from kissing paper to biting paper
wow she buried me i've got the freak virus i've got
i was bitten by a freak she came out of nowhere and just bit my leg.
I've seen tattooed kisses.
Tattooed kisses?
I feel like a tattooed kiss is already, you know, that's inherently sexy.
A bite mark, you can either say it's a zombie bite mark or it's a sexy bite mark.
But it depends on where you put it.
I think it depends on where you put it on your body she's been playing nothing but zombie games in her room for two months i've i've played so many zombie games recently i just can't stop thinking about zombies wherever people could make you regret that you know people will have my dental records that'd be kind of crazy if i if i did that i
think you could be like i i know what you're i have i have some crooked teeth and i have a i have a i have a i have a fang so you you would know that tossing yourself with a bite mark just post your x-rays yeah yeah actually we can do that i'll post my x-rays that would be so insane oh my gosh imagine if then you were murdered and then they were like what's this bite mark on their arm and then they contacted me and they were like what's your relationship to the victim and I'm like
not only she freaky she biting us and spreading MGS brain rot um bit snake ocelot what is me or my oh she's a freak your honor i'm the biter
i'll be like i don't know i don't know who this person is and then they'd be like hold on they'd be like does the name tv table tray mean anything to you i'd be like tv table tray of my chat what what happened to him tell me doc tell to me straight.
For a ghost to have an angelic voice.
What happened to him?
Yeah, that's how I'd find out.
That's so sad.
Can you be normal for once in your life?
I don't have life.
I have afterlife.
I'm already dead.
Anyways guys Oh wait we have to see We have to see Oh You can Wait Huh?
You can go alone Oh I guess if it's just you and Clementine Who is bringing just Ben?
Angelic voice talking about devilish things
Wait so it's Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, I see, I see.
Okay, sorry.
I misunderstood this.
I thought this was like who you were with in like this whole episode or something.
But wait, wait.
Now actually I'm confused.
Oh, wait.
So yes, the three of them are coming with me.
Okay, some people only went.
with Ben some people went with Ben and Kenny okay for the finale some people brought the whole crew I think if we brought Ben I think we would die wait we are gonna die Sir Lee Long milk of the membership thank you so much I think we are gonna die because we're bit
wait so we're definitely wait so we're gonna die we're already dead
Maybe we're immune.
That's why you take Ben only.
Ben would not be a team player.
Some people only went by themselves.
That's crazy.
We have a good team with us.
Yeah.
I like how the majority picked just Keanu.
This was such an intense episode.
is okay i really thought crawford was going to be like i thought they were all gonna be alive i thought we were doing an actual i mean it was a sneaking mission but with zombos you mean that you mean that all the people in this place couldn't handle one zombo it was just the doctor maybe you'll get superpowers yeah yeah yeah
Hmm...
Embarrassing.
Truly!
Can't wait for next episode.
Me too!
Me too.
We'll play in the next couple days.
We have the next episode thing, right?
Survival of the Fish that he said.
So funny.
Next time on...
Dragon Ball...
Sea Safer Zombie.
Wolf Among Us.
People have been recommending that.
Yeah.
There's a new... Is it a Wolf Among Us game?
Or there's a new...
Telltale game or something.
Coming out, no?
Oh, Among Us.
Yeah, that's good.
Wolf Among Us 2.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wonder if I can We can do it in time before the next game, though.
Probably not.
If it's coming out so soon.
Hold on.
Let me look when it comes out.
Among us too.
Oh, does not have a release date.
Okay.
It's been saying soon for years.
Telltale Games delayed the game from 2023-2024.
Oh!
We didn't get one.
game has been coming out soon for like three years you got time okay cool no preview
wait oh i actually i actually teared up this episode first with the dog like the the boy in the dog um yeah
Oh.
It gets you, y'all.
The burying scene.
So sad.
When we lost Chuck, we only lost one person this episode.
We could have lost two.
Well, I guess we lost Bree, but I don't really count her because we just met her.
Wolf Among Us 2 has been in dev for a longer time.
than silk song if you counted it started after season oh no yeah we lost chuck we technically lost molly i guess that's true that is true telltale almost bankrupt oh no kind of just met chuck too i guess that's fair Yeah, he only was around with us for like half an episode.
But he was good.
He saved Clem.
He saved Clem in time.
Man.
Oh.
He was good.
Yeah, Chuck was good.
He didn't deserve the way he died too.
It was crazy.
Well, I guess he actually...
Well, he...
It seems he took himself out and then they ate him.
Ah.
Oh, I think I'll cry next episode.
Lee!
No, Lee!
Oh, because of a stupid zombie jump scare!
I wonder if we'll tell Clem or not.
Well, I guess we have to, right?
Because we're gonna have to leave her, I guess.
Or, I don't know.
I'm still very curious who the radio guy is, too.
Who is that, man?
Why did he decide to take...
And she was upset.
I should have lied to her, so she wouldn't feel inclined to go with the guy.
I recommend Tales from the Borderlands for the thematic 180.
You also need to know absolutely nothing about Borderlands.
Oh, I don't know anything about Borderlands.
Phone guy.
Wow.
Oh.
Alright, well thank you guys for another episode of The Walking Dead and we will finish it next week.
But if anyone's really starved for more Wolf Among Us content, you could always read fables.
The comic it's based on.
Oh, there you go.
Thank you so much everybody.
Ah, I feel a little ah.
Since you're giving us recommendations, if you need more zombie web tunes.
Sweet home.
Oh, I read Sweet home.
Yes, I yes.
I read that one that was coming out.
Thank you, though.
Thanks for the super time!
Otsuminto, everybody!
Otsuminto.
I'm sad this episode.
I'm sad.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Mint was talking about biting us.
The bite of 87.
The bite of 87!
Otsuminto, eat ita-shai!
I'll see you guys later.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye-bye.
Thank you.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
Bye-bye.